Wow.
Hello.
Welcome, welcome in.
Welcome in.
I'm nervous.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you.
I'm nervous.
Why?
Because I feel like... I've never... I've never played any of these games before.
We heard of the High Elves.
What are they, like goats?
They live up on a mountain?
Me either.
It's Skyrim.
Yeah, it's Skyrim!
I... Oblivion is super chill.
Is it?
Okay.
I was always... I never got into these games because they weren't animated.
And then... by the time I... by the time... I...
I don't know.
By the time Skyrim happened, everything...
I was like... oh, it's too... it's too deep.
I can't... I can't join in now.
So...
Um...
Now I'm... now I'm here.
Get mods and make it anime.
No!
Some people were wondering why... you know...
Remastered is more expensive.
But I know that the original has a lot of mods and stuff.
But I just want to play Vanillo.
Since it's my first time ever playing the games.
And then also...
I know the remaster had quality of life updates and stuff.
And...
It's because some people were like...
Oh, the original is so much cheaper.
And things like that.
But...
This is my first time ever playing.
So I've never... I didn't...
You know, I didn't spend money on the previous games.
So...
To me...
I'm not...
It doesn't feel like I'm paying again for the same game.
I'm just...
I'm...
I'm buying a new game.
So...
I don't know.
We'll see.
Your Kamiyoshi is playing through them too.
It's never too late.
But I have seen many Eclipse from this game for some time now.
Of all the silliness that happens in it.
So even for like months, I've been like, man, I kind of want to play this game.
And then the...
Re-Monster happened.
And I was like...
Yippee!
You're gonna full...
Going full curse monstrosity character or regular pretty character?
Well...
Yeah, the lady that goes...
I think it's gonna be pretty.
I think it's gonna look good.
I think it'll look good.
I think.
Actually, I don't...
I know that the character creation in this is pretty extensive, but...
I'm not super into character creation.
It's not like...
You know, I'm not somebody that sits in The Sims and like...
Creates a character's every minute detail for hours and hours.
It's never been my thing, so...
All sliders to the left.
So...
I just...
I'm gonna...
We'll see.
I might get into it.
Who knows?
But I think...
I think we should just start.
No?
Oh my gosh.
I'm nervous.
Liverp...
You could create snake.
I was born 87 years ago.
Oh my god, it's the Elder Scroll!
For 65 years, I've ruled as Tamriel's uncle.
It's him!
But for all these years, I've never been the ruler of my own dreams.
I have seen the gates of oblivion.
Who said it?
Beyond which no waking eye may see.
Behold, in darkness, a doom sweeps the land.
I should pay attention.
Oh, lizard!
Hohohoho, cute!
Hi, dad!
Yeah!
Hold on, I'll read after the cutscene.
How's the audio?
Is it too loud?
Just let me know.
Ooh!
This is the 27th of last seed.
The year of Akatosh, 433.
Akatosh.
He's dead?
The closing days of the third era.
And the final hour of my life.
No, Elder!
Elder Scroll!
Mr. Scroll, no!
No!
No, Mr. Scroll!
Wow, it's so epic!
Whoa!
Is this the original soundtrack?
Like, the rather...
I think they re-dubbed the voices?
Maybe not?
What is this?
Yeah?
Oh!
Same music.
Oh my god, I'm a mouse!
Why do I live in such a tiny home?
Oh, to level up...
Oh, never mind.
Just kidding.
Oh, okay.
20 years later, this music still gets me hyped.
Squeak, squeak, squeak!
Squeakers, squeakers, squeakers!
You versus 100 Wisps, would you win?
Yep.
Also, was it your intention to have your schedule room die on April 30th?
Elder Scrolls lore is convoluted and insane, but thankfully you need to know none of it to play the game.
Yeah, I asked people.
I was like, do I need to know about anything to play?
I could be a lizard.
Okay.
So, guys...
Hold on.
I could be Brendan.
A dark elf.
Whoa.
Mohawk.
Why?
Wait.
The Mohawk...
Like, bald...
Bald...
It's kind of...
Wow.
That's kind of insane.
He's got, like, the stereo...
Like, just get rid of the Mohawk and he's, like, a salary man.
I could be...
Oh, it's the high elf!
I could be a goat elf.
Imperial?
Is this just a guy?
I should be reading, huh?
Okay, hold on.
Reptilian race, well-suited for the treacherous swamps of its homeland, has developed natural immunities to poisons.
They can breathe underwater and are good at picking locks.
You guys, I saw a tutorial on how to lockpick.
I forgot it, though.
Argonians are genetically engineered by sentient trees.
Oh.
But it says they're a reptile.
That doesn't sound like a tree.
Brendan is, in addition to their quick and perceptive grasp of spellcraft, even the humblest of...
Oh, Breton!
Oh my god.
The humblest...
I thought his name was Brendan!
The humblest of Bretons can boast a resistance to magical energies.
They are particularly skilled at summoning and healing magic.
Okay, he's just a guy.
Just look at this.
Just a guy.
Oh.
A guy who's gonna get the rope.
Dark elf, also known as Dunmer.
Or, in their homeland of Morrowind.
The dark elves are noted for their skilled and balanced integration of the sword and bow and destruction magic.
They are resistant to fire...
And can summon an ancestral ghost?
Wait, randomize appearance?
Will that...
Will that make me select it?
Oh!
Oh, no!
Wait.
Oh!
Why are they obsessed with mohawks in this game?
The high elf, also known as Altmer.
In their homeland of Somerset Isle.
The high elves are exceptionally gifted in the arcane arts.
They also boast resistance to illness.
However, they are also somewhat vulnerable to fire for...
Okay.
No vulnerability allowed here.
Me to summon others.
He looks like one of those...
He looks like one of those cats with the flat faces.
Oh my god!
Special skills.
Get this normie out of here.
I can be a cat!
Oh my god, so many cats.
Oh wow, oh my god Taiga.
Oh no, how are you balding when you're a cat?
How is that possible?
Who stressed you out?
Khajiit?
Is that what it's pronounced?
Hailing from the province of Elsweir.
They are intelligent, quick, and agile.
They make excellent thieves due to their natural agility and unmatched acrobatic skills.
All Khajiit can see in the dark.
Elsewhere.
Oh, elsewhere.
No backseating suggestions for final choices, but I suggest playing around in character sliders to see some very cursed possibilities.
I will, thank you.
Hmm.
Bald is just the peak physique of hair growth.
This guy's got hair.
What the hell is up with the mohawks?
I don't understand.
I don't...
Oh, hi.
Oh my god.
Cheetah.
I don't understand.
Oh my gosh.
Snake.
Um.
Nord.
Oh, oh.
By the way, this video is sponsored by Nord VPN.
No, just kidding.
Can you imagine?
He's not bald.
He's just slightly taller than his hairline.
Oh.
That's so positive.
Could you come in all forms, including little cats and big tiger forms, but we only played the bipedal ones in games.
Aw, man.
Citizens of Skyrim.
They are tall and fair-haired people.
Strong and hardy.
Nords are famous for their resistance to cold.
They are highly talented warriors.
Just say it's just a guy.
Wow.
Watching his face, like, expand like that.
Can't wait for her to resist arrest.
I won't get arrested.
Whoa.
Wow.
That eye shadow.
Balding.
Oh.
You should transfer some of that onto the top of your head.
This is so wow.
This looks like one of the- Ah!
Ah!
It's-
He looked fine from the front.
I was gonna say, he looked like one of the Da Vinci twins.
And- Hahaha.
But, wow.
Wee.
Oh my gosh.
And he's got, like, hot pink eyeshadow.
Hahaha.
Wow.
Do you think he was born like that or is it like a botched surgery?
Orc.
The people of the Rothgarian and Dragontail mountains.
Orcish armorers are prized for their craftsmanship.
Craftsmanship.
Orc troops and heavy armor are among the finest in the empire and are fearsome when using their berserker rage.
What a... what a cutie.
I like the lipstick.
Wow, that's the flattest head I've ever seen.
Wow.
What is that?
What's the...
When you wear headphones for too much and it dents your head.
That's what that feels like it should be.
The headset then.
Again with the mohawk.
Oh, hi!
I used to be a lurker but since I lost my Kabuyoshi yesterday...
I'll participate more of my other Oshii streams and activities.
Hi, Neko!
I'm sorry.
It was a really, really nice concert though.
So...
It was so...
Wah.
But thanks for hanging out.
And thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, I saw the stream got blocked but usually...
the companies can fight that.
So...
I have faith that it'll come back.
Yeah, usually they should...
They take care.
They can handle that and take care of it.
Because...
For...
Those kinds of shows they have to get permission for...
All the songs that need.
Well, not permission.
Oh!
Yes, permission!
But also like...
Um...
There's a site.
This is...
I feel...
Pretty common knowledge.
There's a site called Jazzrack.
That...
Uh...
You can check...
Song permission?
For...
Like if it's okay for...
Um...
Streaming...
Or...
Um...
You know...
Uh...
Using at an event.
Things like that.
So...
Um...
If it's...
If it's like streaming okay...
Then...
You know...
Which...
Usually for companies...
They always get the okay.
Um...
Hi Neko!
Welcome!
Thank you!
Uh...
Then...
You know...
It should be...
It should be back.
Hmm...
Yeah...
Sony's copyright bot malfunctioning...
Happens all the time.
Yeah...
Unfortunately...
It does suck though...
That it was like...
Immediately taken down.
Uh...
I hope everyone's...
Okay...
Recently...
Um...
You know...
There was the...
Matara news...
This morning too...
Um...
Uh...
I did...
I didn't know about...
It...
I'm not gonna say much...
But...
I know everyone's kinda feeling a little like...
Antsy...
With...
Everything that's happening...
Um...
Matara's around to stay...
So...
You know...
Unfortunately...
Uh...
Um...
Obviously I...
Don't wanna say anything...
And have her say everything that she wants to say...
But...
Um...
Didn't wanna bring up a sad topic...
No, no, no, no, no...
It's okay...
Uh...
I just wanna make...
I just wanna kind of like...
You know...
Uh...
I...
I feel...
That so many people are like...
Uh...
It's such a turbulent time to be a VTuber fan...
And...
Um...
But...
At the same time...
It's very easy to get bogged down by all the negative news...
Um...
There's a lot of really fun things happening too...
There's always fun events...
Going on...
There's things that people are planning...
So...
Try and always, you know...
Uh...
Keep...
Grounded...
Keep focusing on those sorts of things as well...
Because...
You know...
It's very easy to...
Get...
Distracted...
And...
Only see all the negative that's going on...
Um...
Hmm...
So...
Yeah...
Just uh...
I...
I'm trying to be...
Very...
Hopeful for the future...
So...
I think that...
You know...
At least for me...
I have a lot of really fun things planned...
So I...
Want to...
Keep...
Um...
Focusing on that...
And...
Uh...
You know...
Make...
Why is the music so scary?
Ha ha ha...
And...
Uh...
I wanna keep focusing on that...
So that...
I can help...
Or...
Rather...
Not...
How do I say...
I can...
Um...
Deliver...
My very best...
Stuff to you guys...
And...
Uh...
So...
Yeah...
Ha ha ha...
Sorry, my brain got distracted by the music...
Spooky hunting...
Ha ha ha...
Hmm...
I saw your guest appearance at the call and mix panel get announced today for Ofkai...
Sloppy sisters reunited...
Oh!
Was that announced?
Ha ha ha...
Yeah!
I'm gonna be...
Um...
Well, I'm not a guest...
It's not a sloppy sister...
I don't know if a sloppy sister reunite...
Is...
Ha ha ha...
Maybe in an...
I'm the...
I'm like the creep hiding out behind them...
They all got...
They're all on the red carpet...
And I'm like...
Behind them...
Like...
Ha ha...
Maybe I can get on there too...
Ha ha ha...
So...
But yeah...
I will be...
Offkai...
A little bit...
In...
My own capacity...
And maybe...
Some other things as well...
Something that's...
So...
Mm!
We'll see...
Ha ha ha!
Yeah yeah yeah...
So...
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm...
Thank you guys for the Supertiles...
And the gifted...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Ah...
Creepy stalker Minto...
I don't need a model...
I-he — That's just my natural form.
I mean, Elder's Ring.
Wait, Elder Scroll.
Wait.
No, this is the scroll.
Elder Ring?
That's when two old people get married.
Pyrobug, thank you so much for the time gift.
Thank you!
Elder's Ring.
Who's scrolling?
Thank you for cheering up the wispy key between me two for Halloween.
Plus my cat getting sick.
Oh, the cat's okay.
Gosh, my voice is really dead today.
Vod Watcher.
Hi, thanks for dropping by.
Okay, let's continue.
We got the Red Guard.
The most naturally talented warriors in Tamriel.
In addition to their cultural affinities for many weapons and armor styles, they also have a hearty constitution and natural resistance to disease and poison.
Wait, who else also was resistant to fire?
Someone else was resistant to poison.
Illness.
Oh!
Argonian.
Everybody has no hair and then this guy...
Oh wait, this guy...
These guys actually have a lot of hair.
There's always ups and downs as long as we're all there for each other.
Hmm.
Yeah, I know it's been feeling probably more like more downs than ups.
And I'll be honest, it's...
Uh...
It's...
How do I say?
It's not...
Discouraging isn't the right word.
It's more like...
Kind of just like a...
Disheartening.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think disheartening.
Because...
To me...
I feel that the VTuber...
Sphere thrives when we're all thriving.
And so...
When it feels like...
When I see comments from people saying things like...
Ah...
VTubers are dead!
The...
Everything's imploding!
Ah...
The...
Everything's falling apart!
You know...
To me, I'm just like...
Ah...
There's still so much...
So much good!
And so much going on!
And...
You know...
Ultimately...
VTubers are just a streaming medium.
It's just another different way of...
Not even just streaming...
But another entertainment medium...
That would be saying like...
Twitch streamers...
Are...
Are done!
You know...
Like it's...
Or...
YouTubers are done!
It's just a subset of that!
You know...
But...
Hmm...
I just want...
I just...
Hope that...
If you kind of get...
Uh...
If you kind of only see...
The...
Doomer mentality...
Being spread around...
Um...
It's okay to just kind of...
You know...
Uh...
Oh my god...
I almost said it again...
I almost said get off...
But I wanted to say get off Twitter...
Why do I feel like I've talked about this just so recently?
You know what?
Yeah!
If you're feeling down...
If you're just like...
If all this bad news is bogging you down...
Just get off!
Just let loose!
And get off!
And...
Enjoy yourself!
And don't think about...
The things that make you sad!
You know what?
I'll tell it to you straight!
Hot tag!
There we go...
Yeah!
Long-haired mean though!
I felt like it probably suited the game better!
I don't know why I thought that!
Speak your truth!
Thank you!
I'm getting off!
We're getting off together!
I'm logging off, actually!
Goodbye!
No, just kidding!
Uh...
I'm glad you're here haunting us!
Looking forward to all the big projects you're cooking!
Thank you!
Wood Elf!
Why are there so many Elves?
The Clan Folk of the Western Valand Wood Forest, also known as Bosmer.
Wood Elves are nimble and quick, making them good scouts and thieves.
And there are no finer archers in all of Tamriel.
Their ability to command simple creatures is...
They have to command the creature!
Oops!
Thanks for the permission!
I got you!
I'm getting off!
Get me off this ride!
The noses on these characters are always so crazy!
Andrei goes, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
You look so polite!
Hmm...
Guys, I don't know.
I feel like I should roll a dice.
Hmm...
But this is like...
Good soldiers follow orders!
Swapcoast, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
I...
This is like the most important thing, no?
No!
Because it determines how you play, no?
Oh, I like the ones that dance for me.
This one dances.
Dance, dance, dance, dance.
Oh, they all dance.
Oh!
Not really that important.
Oh, it's not important at all?
Oh!
Um...
Not at all.
Austin, Nadia!
Oh, thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
It's only con...
It determines stats.
Well, there was...
Wait, um...
So this one, the wood elf.
I want to command a simple creature.
I think that sounds fun.
But also...
Was it you?
Good at picking locks.
Can breathe underwater.
That's pretty huge.
And then...
Natural resistance to disease and poison.
I mean, there's probably a lot of disease here, no?
The wood elves are carnivores that eat people.
Wait, what?
Diseases don't do much.
Wait, these are cannibals?
They're friendly cannibals!
You spent your child...
Oh wait, origin.
You spent your childhood in Grotwood.
Near the region devastated by Molagbal.
The foul energies still linger there and your resilience grew amidst the danger.
The border region that saw you grow is plagued by anger and resentment after centuries of war.
You quickly learned how to soothe people and avoid unnecessary conflicts.
No, no.
I want to cause conflicts.
I don't know.
I'm feeling wood elf.
I can't imagine conclusiveness.
Oh wait, there's stats!
Bad intelligence.
Lots of strength...
Wait.
Who has the best luck?
Wait...
Magicka...
Ooooooooo!
Oh.
They all have the same luck.
Why is your willpower so low?
He's just like, yeah.
I give in.
Maybe.
Well, the strength is not very high.
If I get myself into trouble.
But I can just book it.
I can just leave.
Hand to hand.
We got some CQC.
Acrobat.
Sneak 15.
But who needs sneak if you just got brute strength?
A dice roll isn't bad if you are overwhelmed.
I think I am overwhelmed.
Let's see.
Roll.
Dice.
One.
Through.
Ten.
Roll.
One.
It wants me to be a lizard.
But.
I was going to make my character really anime.
Remember how I mentioned I never played these games before?
Because they weren't anime enough.
I was going to make them really anime.
I feel like you can't customize your character as a lizard.
No.
Can you?
You can?
Hold on.
Oh!
Let's see.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
I can be kind.
Or stern.
Turn.
Oh!
Ooh!
Oooh!!
Mm-hm-hm-hm-hm-hm-hm-hm-hm-hh-hm-hm sing-hm-hm.
Round.
The cheekbones.
Whoa!
It's really weird watching them move through the face!
You!
Ohh!
Oh.
Thin wide.
Pick a body first.
Body type.
Oh, it can be old.
What the?
Oh.
I was like... Suddenly, I developed the best skincare routine known to Argonian.
Argonian.
Argonian maids are very popular in lore.
Oh, yeah.
Mogu talked about that.
Why?
It's so funny.
Wait, can I zoom in?
No.
Type 2, type 1.
Oh.
Oh my god.
The skincare routine.
Drop it, queen.
Drop it.
Nothing even changes when I become old.
Just like... It's like when dogs become old and their snout is a little more white.
Hmm.
I still don't know, guys.
Wait, now we're ladies.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Female cat.
Hmm.
I still... I don't know.
Do I go with the wood elf?
I'm self-pulled.
Cat girl.
You guys are such freaks.
Did I miss a birthday?
Say hi and ask if I could get a quick happy birthday.
Zelda stuck!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Thank you so much for this every time.
Have a happy birthday.
We could be Shrek Fiona.
I think I'm gonna go with the wood elf, you guys.
Oh my god.
Anime haircut.
Okay.
I'm gonna go with the wood elf.
People will call you short.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
In the game?
Old.
Young.
We're gonna be... We're gonna be... We're gonna be a fresh-faced little elf.
Wood elves are short.
Oh my
god.
Thank you so much.
Thanks.
I don't know what this is in response to.
Because it was from 10 minutes ago.
But thanks, Phil!
You want a hag elf?
We can make her a little haggard.
Like that.
I kind of maybe want her a little tan.
She's... She's like a gyaru type.
Let's see.
All right.
Oh yeah, baby.
Let's see.
Oh.
We're gonna... Okay.
Time to make our super-duper cute anime girl.
Oh my gosh.
Look how cute she is already.
Oh.
She's... She's like... Oh.
She... This... This girl would have toast in her mouth run into school.
Well, she doesn't go... 10 years ago.
All right.
Hold on.
The eyes are the most important part, though.
Large.
That's it?
That's as large as they go?
No.
Larger.
No!
Why are their eyes so red?
It's... Ooh.
It's freaky.
Click the number.
What number?
There is no number.
Click the number, you can... type... custom sizes.
Oh, this?!
Oh, maybe we change our plans then.
I was gonna have her be the cutest... the cutest!
Okay, next.
Now, I'm gonna make... E.T.
I need a reference photo.
Okay.
So far, not so bad.
Okay, hold on.
Let's start... let's start with the brows.
We'll go back to the brows.
We need them... we need them wide and high, baby.
Nope.
Downwards is good.
Is good.
Okay.
Con... not so much concave, but a little more round because we're gonna have it come down...
Wait, should I change my body type?
Are we gonna be sexy E.T.?
If you made her the cutest, she'd just be you.
Stop.
Cheekbones... high.
And... It's hard to tell.
Wait, let me change her hair real quick.
Head.
Wait.
Hair.
Here, hold on.
E.T.
is bald.
Okay, okay.
This is looking good.
Ah!
Okay, okay, hold on.
Back to the head.
Okay.
Brows.
I wish I could... Oh!
Oh, that's the tone.
Never mind.
Hmm... It's just a little more curved in.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
This might work.
No, I still think this looks better.
E.T.s are more round.
E.T.
is more round.
I think.
Can we get bald Minto to match?
You would want that, wouldn't you?
You would want that.
How do I make my head bigger?
Hmm...
I'm looking at E.T.
It's not... I wish I could expand this part.
Wide.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Wait, then?
Like so.
Yes.
I think it's more in the middle.
And E.T.
has these beautiful blue eyes.
E.T.
is...
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, wow.
E.T.
is...
Um...
Oh my god!
I'm...
I have...
I have scurvy or something.
Wait, I can be...
Blue?
Pink?
Pink!
Oh no.
I can be mint.
None of these are E.T.
The eyes are so red.
I know.
Bruised?
Why are they bruised?
But E.T.
has got some crazy wrinkles.
You know what?
Let's...
Let's make them old.
More E.T.
like.
Very good!
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you!
E.T.
Phone home.
Flushed.
Freckles!
Can't even see them.
I'm way too old.
Do you guys see the vision?
Yeah, you see the vision?
Do you see it?
Do you see the vision?
Actually, this looks more like E.T.'s eyes.
E.T.
doesn't have ears?
Oh!
There's no ear customization?
E.T.
also does not have a chin.
But like that, I think would be...
Wait.
Nah, I think like that is good.
Like...
E.T.'s got a really long neck.
Nah...
And then...
Like...
Uh...
I'll do wide.
No!
Not wide.
I lied.
I died.
Um...
Does anybody...
When do you ever even get to see my character?
Isn't it...
Isn't it not...
Is it not a first-person game?
Why do they look so upset?
Dobby!
It does kind of look like Dobby.
Do you guys see the vision, though?
I think I'm really...
Actually starting to see the vision.
I
think I'm actually really starting...
Oh gosh.
I wish I didn't...
Hold on...
Look, look, look.
Tilt it up...
And thin...
No.
Wide.
Oh my god.
What's a Cellion?
Oh, I've never even heard of that before.
E.T.
Fun home.
What does E.T.
look like from the side?
You know what?
It doesn't matter.
I've never played any Elder Scrolls.
I'm looking forward to watching your mods.
Because I applied for an internal promotion.
So cool!
You got this.
I kind of want the eyes to be...
Like, definitely down.
But they look too bored.
You know?
Maybe if I can do the brows.
More like that, maybe.
More like that helps.
I wish they were more...
Pronounced.
You know?
How is this cursed?
It's E.T.
Who doesn't...
Do you guys know the E.T.
ride?
At Universal.
And then you tell it...
You say...
I guess at the beginning you say...
What your name is.
And at the end of the ride...
It will say like...
Thank you.
And then say...
The ride...
Can we get a side-by-side?
Yeah!
Yeah, that's a great idea.
And so people will like...
Go and say like...
Their name is Jeff.
But like the entire cart.
And so...
And so E.T.
will just be like...
Thank you.
Jeff.
E.T.
Oh my...
Okay, this is the picture I've been basing it off of.
No!
I want to...
I want to create this first.
And then I will show you.
Wait, the forehead.
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's all really coming together.
Actually, strangely enough...
E.T.
does not really have that big of a head.
Like a forehead.
This actually looks so normal.
What was it before?
Yeah.
Now it's like...
It's really coming together.
Okay, and then the mouth.
Wait, did I do face?
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's E.T!
Wait, what is this forehead?
Oh.
No, E.T.'s is actually kind of concave.
It seems.
Hmm.
Okay.
Mouth.
Purse.
Happy!
And we'll do lower?
Oh.
Protruding.
It's pretty normal.
It's pretty average.
Happy!
E .T!
No.
I wish.
Mouth.
Chin.
Distance.
Very short.
No, no.
Okay.
We gotta keep it the way it is then.
Lips.
Deflated.
Inflated.
E.T.
doesn't really have lips.
So let's do...
Let's do this.
A bit.
Don't look at the size.
Oh.
Do that.
I'm not puckered for sure.
You look like an apple.
I left in the first...
It's not me!
It's E.T.
Let's also...
I'm gonna pick...
Um...
Oh my god.
Wow.
That actually really suits her.
I want them piercing blue eyes.
You know?
No, not piercing enough.
Like, I want people to look at E.T.
and be like...
Oh, you have blue eyes.
Like the meme?
Exactly like the meme.
I want to get rid of the...
The eyelid.
The red eyelid.
It's freaking me out.
Yeah, this is good.
This is good.
Eyeshadow color...
None.
Wow!
Wow.
Ooh-wee!
E.T.
be styling...
Sheer lipstick.
Or...
I guess we are doing sexy E.T.
So maybe...
Our eyeshadow color...
What would be a sexy...
Color?
When you think of sexy color...
Mint?
Oh my gosh.
You guys are so right.
No, I kind of don't like it.
I think I kind of want to just be regular E.T.
Oh, goth E.T.
Nah, I think I'll just be regular E.T.
I'm not just regular.
Okay, let me show you the image...
That I've been basing this off of.
Oh, I already have...
I already saved it.
Okay.
Glup...
Sheet-o?
No, no.
You're mistaken.
You're mistaken!
Okay, here we go.
Ready?
Three, two, one...
E.T.
Phone hub...
E .T.
phone hub...
How did you nail this?
Woohoo!
E.T.
The only thing that's bothering me are the ears.
And I wish I could make the forehead like a little bit more concave.
You know?
Or like right here?
It's not the forehead though.
It's like just the head.
It's not the cheeks.
The face.
No.
Can the brows be bigger?
No!
I can't make the brows bigger eyes.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Bro.
Yeah, no.
They can't be bigger.
Bigger eyes?
I can't.
They're as big as they can be.
It's just...
We're just gonna have to understand that E.T.
Super bushy brow.
Well, should I like restart on an orc or something?
Needs white sclera.
I don't have that though.
Maybe red would be better.
Oh, actually that looks better.
That actually does look better.
Than this one.
Like it was...
This before...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll go with this.
Wait, where'd I go?
This one.
I can't believe E.T.
came to Earth...
And they experimented on him...
And cut off his ears.
This is E.T.
before that all happens.
Done.
Okay.
I think I'm ready to start the game.
Don't need to do hair.
A little darker, maybe.
E.T.
No hair.
No.
Wait, I could...
Hair tip color?
Wait a second.
Hold on.
How does the E.T.
song go again?
That's...
Jurassic Park.
Wait a second.
Wait, isn't there a part of the movie...
Where E.T.
Where's a wig?
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm gonna pull it up.
I'm gonna pull up a picture.
It's too...
Too perfect.
Oh.
I think I have to go with...
Wait.
Which one do you guys think?
I feel like the Karen cut just...
It's not accurate, but it just works.
I can't...
Which one?
This is one...
The E.T.
Phone manager.
Oh, it does hide the ears.
Oh my god.
Well, they both do.
It looks so good.
I can't get over it for me.
This is...
You can make it longer.
Oh.
Woo.
Short.
Long.
Wait.
How does this get longer?
Oh.
That's strange.
Nothing happens.
No.
I think...
Oh my gosh.
The wig was literally the final touch.
It's too good.
But I wanted to see the...
Okay.
It was just...
Remember it's this brown, you guys.
Because it's already...
It's already like the perfect color.
I just wanted to see how...
If we can make it...
Like Minto, you know?
Tip color.
That's not the hair tip.
Salt and pepper.
What's that mean?
Eyebrow color.
Wait.
There we go.
Maybe we can...
Do...
Maybe like a little bit of shadowing, you know?
Doesn't really do much.
Hmm.
A little graying.
Oh!
I get it.
Gradient contrast.
I don't see...
Oh!
I do see a difference, actually.
Like, this looks more blended, I think.
And this is where you can see the mint gradient amount.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa.
If we do...
If you do like that...
Minto!
Oh!
Mike knows many things.
Mike knows many ghosts who relive their lives each day.
Mike sees a ghost playing a game, wonders if she plays the same game again or new one.
Yes.
All right.
E.T.
Everybody.
Give it up for...
Wait.
Actually, maybe this color is better.
No, no, no.
It's a little more sandy, right?
It's a little more sandy of a blonde.
We'll do go darker, too.
There.
I think that's better.
Perfect!
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Salt and pepper, zero.
We want to...
Okay.
All right.
Are we ready to...
To...
I...
Hold on.
I don't want to see.
No, I still think this one...
E.T.
phone manager.
Character's name.
E.T.
Wait.
How can we...
How can we make...
How can we make it cute?
How can we make it like a cute like...
Minty?
No, no, no.
E.T.
That's perfect.
E .T.
E.T.
Improved endurance.
Name cannot... Oh.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay, it has to be... It has to be like that.
E-T-ina.
There we go.
Yay!
E-T!
Are you sure?
Yes.
Where am I?
Am I in jail?
Press shift.
Oh, to sprint, left shift.
I feel like I'm already so fast.
Oh my god.
Hi.
Not a little far from the forest, huh?
Looks like your days of woodland frolicking have come to a tragic end.
To go from the gladed realm of Valenwood to a rat-infested hoe like this.
How very sad.
What am I in for?
Those walls must feel like they're closing in on you.
Yeah.
Pretty soon, you'll go mad.
And the guards will cut your throat just to stop the ranting.
That's right.
You're going to die in here, Woodell.
No.
Die.
E-T needs to go home.
Hey, you hear that?
The guards are coming.
For you.
Hee hee hee hee ha ha.
Hee hee ha.
Or lock that door behind us.
No, I'm fine.
I'm eavesdropping.
The messenger only said they were attacked.
No, they're dead.
Hee hee ha.
I know it.
What's this prisoner doing here?
This cell is supposed to be off limits.
There's nobody in here.
Usual mix up with the watch.
I...
Never mind.
Get that gate open.
Yes, please.
Stand back, prisoner.
Oh.
We won't hesitate to kill you if you get in our way.
Okay.
No sign of pursuit, sir.
Stay put, prisoner.
Good.
Let's go.
We're not out of this yet.
What's happening?
You...
I've seen you.
Yeah, I'm from that famous movie.
Let me see your face.
You are the one from my dreams.
Oh!
Then the stars were right.
And this is the day.
Gods give me strength.
Oh.
What's going on?
Assassins attacked my sons, and I am next.
My blades are leading me out of the city along a secret escape route.
I'm not gonna let this guy die.
By chance, the entrance to that escape route leads through your cell.
Oh.
Um, why am I in jail?
Perhaps the gods have placed you here so that we may meet.
As for what you have done, it does not matter.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
That is not what you will be remembered for.
Everybody in my village, probably.
I'll be remembered for my famous movie directed by Steven Spielberg, E.T.
Extraterrestrial.
Yeah, and I ate them.
Who are you?
I am your emperor, Uriel Septim.
By the grace of the gods, I serve Tamriel as her ruler.
You are a citizen of Tamriel, and you too shall serve her in your own way.
He looks like my dad.
Like, like E.T.'s dad.
Like, you know, with the eyes.
Not like my, my actual dad.
Um, what should I do?
You will find your own path.
Take care.
There will be blood and death before the end.
Please, sire.
We must keep moving.
That's, that's, that's, that's, um, Jean-Luc Picard!
Whoa.
Better not close this one.
There's no way to open it from the other side.
Okay.
This doesn't concern you, prisoner.
Looks like this is your lucky day.
Just stay out of our way.
Okay.
So I get to leave, or?
See ya, bozo.
Take a bone.
Wait.
How do I take that bone?
Take that skull.
Take this other bone.
Can he get way down in this game for taking too many bones, or?
Holy cow!
Oh, you can?
Okay.
I just won't take so many.
Um, how do I get up?
Wait, I think I, oh, there we go.
Okay, phew.
Um, okay.
I'm on my way.
Here we go.
It's kind of spooky down here.
How do I open my inventory?
Inventory.
Empty?
What are you talking about?
Oh.
My gear.
I gotta say, I have so many bones.
I can't equip it.
I think it's a weapon, no?
Oh.
What's over here?
Nothing.
Is this place booby-trapped?
Is she playing E.T.?
Yeah.
Oh!
Gosh, they're slow.
Close up left.
Protect the Emperor.
What's happening?
Protect yourself.
I don't have anything.
How do I protect myself?
Are you alright, sire?
We're clear for now.
Captain Reno?
She's dead.
Oh my god!
It's fine, sire.
But we have to keep moving.
Oh.
Shh, shh, shh.
Uh.
I'll take that.
How could they be waiting for us here?
Uh.
Yoink.
Take off?
Don't know, but it's too late to go back now.
They probably don't care, right?
Don't worry, sire.
We will get you out of here.
Her corpse and eat it?
Which?
Yeah!
Whoa!
I got a katana!
They won't be the first to underestimate the blades.
I'll take point.
Let's move.
You stay here, prisoner.
Don't try to follow us.
Why not?
Oh.
To ready your weapon, press F.
To attack, press left.
Okay, that's what I have.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, it's a rat!
Oh, there's multiple rats!
I'm blocking.
I can search the rat.
Rat meat.
I'll have you know.
I will take everything for now.
Can I eat it?
They look so fluffy.
I'm, like, charming.
Actually.
So, they said don't fall.
Oh, wait.
I probably can't go this way.
Yeah.
I need a key.
Oh, my God!
Assassins!
I didn't just notice these guys.
Wait.
If I put on their clothes, will they kill me?
Will they be, like...
They didn't even come with anything.
How are you supposed to kill...
Oh, I'll take that.
What?
No?
They're kind of...
They're kind of, like...
They got fancy outfits, no?
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Wait.
What do you look like naked?
Okay.
How do I get rid of their clothes?
I don't care about it.
Wait.
No!
My wig!
No.
Wait.
How do I...
Take it off.
E.T.
Remove.
joins a cult?
Shift-click.
Oh, thank you.
E.T.
You are not decent.
I kind of like the...
Nah.
We'll take off the...
Oh, shift-click drops it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
Look.
They're just...
We folded it up really neatly for them.
It's nice.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Here I go.
What's in here?
Some gold?
An axe?
Let's do it.
A shield?
A skeleton?
Wow!
He's got a lot of stuff.
Holy cow.
How many?
Uh, yes.
The boots?
Take his clothes?
I hear something.
Now that you have arrows, pick up the bow and practice using it.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
I don't have time to practice!
Thanks, game.
Very easy.
Oh!
Ah!
Hoo!
Ha!
If you have a lockpick, you can try to pick locks.
Move the lockpick from...
From...
A...
D...
Press...
Wait.
Uh...
Press W to move your mouse.
Or move your mouse to move the pick upward.
When the tumbler reaches the top of the lock, you will hear a metallic sound.
Press space to secure it.
When all tumblers are secured, the...
Is that it?
She did it.
First try.
Yeah?
How many?
Yes.
Okay.
Trying to see if there's any other chests in...
That looks...
New.
Are you still alive, goblin shaman?
Why do you have a chameleon?
Is that my cousin?
No!
I'm an elf, remember?
Oh, I...
I...
Why am I not just pressing R?
Sorry.
I'm going to...
Oh.
Tab.
Uh...
Oh.
Tab is the same?
I'm going to check my weapons.
Let's see.
We got...
Oh, my katana is still the best thing we got.
Oh, I'm heavy.
E.T.
is weak.
E .T.
Doesn't have much...
Strength.
You open the door.
Okay.
Oh, caps lock.
Is that what...
Wait, how do I...
Now practice catching spells.
Open your journal.
Magic.
Clairvoyance.
How do I do it?
Cast.
Cast?
See?
Other tabs?
Oh.
Wait, what do you mean?
Exit the inventory.
Cast it by pressing C.
Oh.
Guide you towards the next step of your journey.
But also, I want to...
Use the...
Bow and arrow.
That we got.
Where'd he go?
Where'd that rack go?
How do I...
Okay.
No.
What?
No, no.
Don't see me.
No, no, no.
It's just...
You have to equip the arrows.
I missed.
He's right in front of me.
I got it.
In the original Oblivion, when you got over Cumbered, you couldn't even move?
No way.
Maybe we'll get to that point.
I'm so slow, though.
We can drop some stuff.
So, dropping...
Wait.
Dropping stuff is just shift-click.
Should be a way to make a hotbar for spells and weapons.
Press Caps Lock.
Wait, what do you mean Caps Lock?
You have trick...
No, I turned...
I did Caps Lock off.
See?
I am over-encumbered.
You cannot carry any more items.
Okay.
My gosh.
I'm working on it.
Okay, we're gonna put on...
Wow.
E.T.
The one thing we must never do...
Is...
The one thing we must never do is cover our face.
E.T.
Let's see.
What do I not need?
Maybe some...
Some...
Rusty daggers.
Um...
I have three clubs!
Oh, wait.
I've been looking at...
I'm stupid.
I've been looking at this.
Oh, this is how much they're worth, right?
And then this is...
How good they are?
Okay, okay.
Um...
Yeah, so wait.
Then why is this katana so heavy?
I'm gonna get rid of one of the axes.
Wait, I'm still over-encumbered!
What do I have?
Too much rat meat!
Wait, where's my health?
How can I...
Is this my health down here?
I got a shield.
Red is health.
Oh, okay.
Diablo.
Mana, health, stamina.
Okay.
The bones.
Oh my gosh!
Why are they so heavy?
Oh, they're kind of heavy.
Even the mugs and stuff.
Okay!
Oh, nope.
Not even yet.
Um...
Uh...
I don't wanna get...
Wait.
This is what...
I don't wanna get rid of what I'm wearing, but...
I guess it's not that much better than this, huh?
It's only just by one.
But it's so heavy.
Drop the shield.
Drop the clubs.
You know what?
Yeah, they are only just one.
How many?
Drop them.
Okay.
There we go.
Now we're...
We're all good, baby.
Okay.
Maybe I should...
Look, I made a mess.
All my...
All my litter is here.
Oh!
Oh, it's an army!
Oh, it's a family!
Oh!
It's a zombie!
Uh, they're infighting.
Let them...
Oh, never mind.
There's zombies in this game!
This was...
Damage fatigue.
Why are there zombies in this game?
The character looks like she needs to phone home.
You got it!
That's my character.
E.T.
The Great.
Why is...
Why is it if I press tap?
Is there like a...
Easier way to get to inventory?
I'm gonna equip my boat.
Sorry.
E.T.
You guys are so right.
Who?
More zombies?
Not on my watch.
Eye for inventory.
Okay.
Thank you.
You just froze there.
Yeah!
Oh, no!
Sorry.
My bad.
I wish I could pick up arrows.
I wish I could pick them back up.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Wait.
I shot...
Not these guys.
My athletics increase.
Hell, yeah.
Did I shoot you?
Yeah!
For now, we'll collect them.
You have enough, though?
Is it that 60 that I have right there?
I hear something.
Oh, it's a rat.
What the?!
I think I literally threaded the needle.
Oops.
I don't think it hurts to...
Take it back, though, for now.
You know?
Oh, I'm fatigued.
Take it back.
Take it out!
I'm fine for now, probably.
Why is it so spooky?
Oh, it's so spooky.
There's...
Now I know there's zombies here and everything.
Uh-oh.
What's going on here?
It's a spooky game.
Is it really?
Ah!
Thank you.
It can get scary.
Not only is that rat meat edible, you can become a master alchemist.
By shoving everything you find down your pile.
Really?
I took some of it.
I'll take it.
Why not?
Oh.
Nothing gets past E.T.
Anything in the barrel?
Nothing.
Any food here?
Oh, lettuce!
Oh, a tomato!
Not an apple!
I wish I could sell the bones.
What is this place?
Someone's just throwing their bones and garbage down here.
A rusty helmet.
If I wear this...
It'll cover our luscious locks.
How much you carry depends on your strength.
Gaining a few points...
Put strength early can help the looting process.
If you crouch your attacks, do bonus damage.
I'm also going to switch...
Back to my katana.
Looking good!
Alright.
It's scary in here!
My athletics increase.
From walking?
How...
What if we started at zero?
Any more zombies?
Every bit helps.
Eww!
How many?
Can I get drunk in this game?
E.Tina had never walked before.
Clearly!
You can!
What if I drink it all right now?
Oh!
Oops!
Ouch!
Oh, bad.
I should've crouched, huh?
Beer clock calls.
Where is it?
Beer?
Drain intelligence on self...
For 60 seconds.
Restore fatigue!
My willpower is being drained.
My intelligence is going down!
That's a big rat!
Oh!
Oops!
Oh, I thought my...
My vision was a little...
Oh!
Skelly man!
Mushrooms!
Does the skelly man have anything on it?
Wait!
Why is this fresh?
Who was here?
The zombo?
He's got some gold!
So happy I get to see my favorite ghost play some old school jank.
Happy birthday!
Aw, man.
I wanna keep lick...
Uh...
Not licking...
Pick...
Lick...
No.
Pick...
Locking!
Taking some...
Mushroom?
Oh!
That doesn't look good.
Wait.
Okay.
Uh...
We're getting into actual cult territory, I believe.
Wait a second.
You can shortcut items and spells.
Yeah?
In your journal, select an item or spell and press R to select a spot.
Then use your mouse to equip your choice.
Pressing 1 to 8 will also equip that shortcut immediately.
The game only autosaves when you transition areas or when you open your menu every 15 minutes.
Quick save with F5.
Is that actually it?
Oh!
It is!
Thank you!
Wait.
So if I...
Do wanna...
Mmm...
Like my magic.
What the hell is chameleon?
Chameleon on self.
What the hell does that do?
Beast tongue.
Can only be used once a day.
Destruction!
One.
Flash bolt.
Oh no.
Heal mine or wood.
I guess that's important.
Chameleon.
Chameleon is the lesser invisible.
Oh.
Resist disease!
Okay.
What the heck is that thing?
Uh oh.
I'm going into their house.
I got a stink horn.
I'm going in!
Put your bow and arrow...
Oh!
I can do that!
I can put bow and arrow with shortcuts?
That's kinda huge.
Wait.
I didn't even think about that.
Uh...
Oh!
Oops.
I was gonna press...
I was gonna do four.
Uh...
Wait.
Okay.
Let's redo.
That's two.
Okay.
Three.
We'll do...
From three on is our magic.
So we got that.
And then we got...
Four.
We'll do...
And then...
Actually four is our fire.
And five is our fire.
I'm ready.
Finger on the key.
Ready to fire?
Oh.
Okay.
Some cloth.
Cheese wheel.
Uh...
All of it.
Thanks.
I'm encumbered.
The goblin ahead is not as...
You can sneak by pressing left control.
Wait.
But I'm over encumbered.
Cheese is heavy.
Oh.
I gotta get rid of the cheese.
I wish I...
I can't put it back.
Oh.
Eat it.
Just eat it.
Okay.
Where is...
Oh.
My cheese.
Oh my god.
I'm full of cheese.
The closed eye indicates you are undetected.
Wait.
I don't see a closed eye.
There's no closed eye.
Huh.
Is it the middle?
The middle.
When a fight begins, I will flicker.
Oh, so it's the...
Like the crosshair?
Okay.
If I shoot a fireball at him...
Where'd he go?
Fireball is not sneaky.
Yeah, but I would...
I could do it.
Where'd he go?
He's got...
A dinosaur?
Oh.
Never mind.
He's roasting a rat.
What if
he was nice?
Nice.
Dang.
He probably wasn't though.
He was probably really, really mean.
Poison of illness.
Novice mortar and pestle.
What the hell is that?
Go in your inventory and find it.
Activate it to create potions!
Oh!
I need a break.
This is my place now.
Oh, man.
Gosh.
It ain't easy taking over goblin homes and...
Wake it up.
E.T.
get up.
Tina!
Tina, get up.
I didn't want that.
Hungry.
Where's my rat?
Oh, I have so much rat.
Wait, shouldn't this not be cooked rat meat?
So I can just eat raw rat?
What the?
Wait, how did... Wait, I messed it up.
Whatever.
Easy.
What did I make my... I think it was...
Okay, my bow and arrow is one.
And my katana is two.
Okay.
Let's sneak.
There's probably other goblins around here.
Oh!
How?
How the hell?
Oh.
Oh, good thing I didn't run.
Oh, I thought it said goblin stinker.
I'm over encumbered.
Oh my gosh, I'm so weak.
I should have become a...
E.T.
Why are you so small?
Goblin stinker.
Oh, bear pelt is heavy.
But look how much gold we get from it.
Hmm.
Time to eat some meat.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Oh!
You...
You tried.
Wait, but this is only one.
Why is there whispers?
Who's whispering?
Making potions?
Oh yeah, how do I...
Let's see.
It's in here?
This thing?
Oh!
Oh, tutorial.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Combine ingredients with similar effects to create potions and poisons.
Your alchemy skill will make your creations more powerful.
The more potions you create, the higher your alchemy skill will increase.
Use additional apparatuses to improve the strength of the potions you create.
So if I'm like full...
Oh, okay.
Lettuce...
Tomato...
That...
How does it create...
I...
Okay.
I made something.
This doesn't make anything.
Weirdest BLT ever?
Yeah, exactly.
What do you mean weird?
It's probably delicious.
Bones.
Ah, no bones about it.
Alright, let's keep going.
Oh, that's a lot of fire.
What is that?
Anybody around?
Oh, dead rat.
Rat sandwich.
Okay, there you go.
I kind of want my sword.
Okay.
I'm sneaky.
I'm so sneaky.
I'm also...
Stealing?
Wait.
Wait, go back.
What was the...
Oh, there we go.
Easy.
Default FOV is pretty low if you ever feel motion sick.
Oh, thank you.
Do you guys think it's okay?
I'm over encumbered.
Arrows.
That's okay.
Might be time to get rid of our iron.
Our armor, I mean.
This is fine.
We can get rid of those.
Okay.
Do you need two bows?
What if one breaks?
Yikes.
Look, it's already at 91.
Don't I need another bow?
What's that?
Oh, it's a guy.
I could shoot him.
Oops.
He didn't notice that.
Oh, my God.
He also has arrows.
But I got his ass first.
Oh.
Yeah.
Take some apples.
Push the logs.
Wait, you can do that?
Oh, there was another guy.
He didn't even notice his first friend, though.
There was a second guy.
Why?
The goblins are stupid.
Can I get burnt on this?
That's some rat meat.
Anything else in here?
No?
Okay.
He was oblivious.
Did you guys hear that?
Lockpick.
Of course I'll take.
What do you got?
I don't need your short sword.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to be going into their whole ass village.
Wait.
No, no, no.
I...
Okay.
Take.
Goblin slayer time.
Who else is in here?
I heard you.
Wait, what?
What is the footsteps that are counting down?
Above me.
Goblins don't have pockets on their loincloths.
Where are you reaching?
Oh, your objective marker.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Goblin berserker.
Thank you.
It does have a shield.
I think I have a shield too, though.
Rough leather shield.
I think his is...
Not as good as mine.
Anybody that can sneak attack you?
Yes, indeedy.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
You can run this way.
Ah!
Oops.
I thought...
I thought there was a...
I thought it was a...
I thought it was like a...
Like a little cliff.
You know?
You had to run around.
Golly.
Yeah, like a little chasm.
Exactly.
What is the eye?
Why is the eye, though?
Is open.
Who sees me?
Or who's around, rather?
That guy over there!
Whoa.
What the?
I
don't know what it's up.
They can also hear you.
They can?
I'm trying to see where I... Oh, here, there's a rat.
Oh, can I not go through the... the fence?
Oh.
There's two of them.
Sneak.
Alright, very good.
Goblin Slayer would be proud.
I am that Goblin Slayer.
I saw a guy over there, though.
I saw, I saw.
I'm still... crouched.
I'm still sneaking around.
That guy's huge!
There's one more rat.
Oops.
The drop off on this is... Yoik.
Okay.
Yoiks.
Alright.
I think I can take him.
Oh, no.
My fatigue.
We're fine.
Oh, they're tough.
I'm tougher.
I'm the toughest there ever was.
I'm the toughest there ever is.
I'm the... I'm the... I'm the brains here.
And the brawn.
I'm the toughest there ever be.
Take your drinks.
Take your ale.
Take your chests.
Oh.
Repair hammer.
What's that?
You found a repair hammer.
In order to repair your weapons and armor...
Oh.
Good, good, good.
Let's see.
What other things you got around here?
Let's go over here.
The powers go into her head.
I'm...
I'm the greatest to ever do it!
Of course I can be cocky.
That looks...
Fancy!
Whoa!
Flawed sapphire.
Gold nugget!
Yippee!
Your decorations are...
Actually quite nice.
What do you got?
Ooh.
I'll take your arrows...
And your petty soul gem.
And I'm...
His staff?
I can take that!
Whoa!
Wait.
What is this?
Can I use this?
Oh my god!
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You guys see his mouth?
E.T.
Phone home.
Oh, what's that?
Let's go back to my...
Let's go back to my sword.
Yeah, you guys are kind of in the way.
It's okay, though.
I'm sneaking.
I'm sneaking again.
Oh, uh, F5.
Thank you, whoever taught me F5.
Quick save.
Are we out?
Is this it?
Wait a second!
You're welcome.
Yeah!
F9 is quick load as well.
Oh.
Why aren't they next to...
I guess...
I guess maybe actually it's better that they're not next to each other, huh?
So, I'm still confused about the zombie.
Why it exists.
Oh my gosh, it's so dark in here.
Yeah, misload.
You should find a defensible spot and protect the emperor.
Oh.
Just kidding, they're talking.
I'll go help.
Maybe.
Who's the baddies?
Hi!
Hello!
Why are you looking at me like that?
I...
Sire, we have to go now.
Not yet.
Let me rest a moment longer.
I'll talk to him.
Hello!
Dammit, it's that prisoner again!
Kill her!
She might be working with the assassins.
I'm not!
No, she is not one of them.
Thank you.
She can help us.
She must help us.
Yeah, I'll help you.
Oh!
They cannot understand why I trust you.
They've not seen what I've seen.
Your dreams.
How can I explain?
Listen.
You know the nine.
How they guide our fates with an invisible hand.
Uh...
The nine...
The nine guide...
Uh...
I don't know.
The who?
I don't even know this.
What is...
What do you...
The nine guide and protect...
I've observed the nine all my days.
And I chart my course...
...by the cycles of the heavens.
The skies are marked with numberless sparks.
Each a fire.
The guy behind here is frozen.
And every one a sign.
I know these stars well.
And I wonder...
Which sign marked your birth?
Oh!
Chula's my birth sign!
Okay.
The serpent!
What is a steel?
Oh!
This is...
It gives us like...
More...
Buffs.
We are the warrior.
Fortify endurance.
That's...
I like that.
Fortify strength.
I like that too.
Mage.
Agility, luck, and speed.
I like that.
There's a lady.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's lady!
Fortify willpower...
And endurance.
The lover.
Lover's kiss.
It paralyzes the target for 10 seconds.
Wait.
What's the serpent do?
Serpent spell.
Deal three points of damage for 20 seconds.
It also cures poison, dispels 90 points, and damage fatigue 100 points to the caster.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
What?
To me?
That sucks!
Wait.
Like...
I take 100 point...
I take 100 point fatigue damage, and...
Also...
90 point...
Oh.
It just uses stamina.
It's bad.
What's this guy?
The lord?
Shield?
Resist magic.
If you...
Pick the lover, you have to go two every time you use the ability.
Yeah, but like...
Would I remember to use it?
Oh my gosh, it's Regirock!
Quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack, quack.
Fortify Magicka, spell absorption, Stunt and Magicka.
Opens locks of average difficulty.
Can be used once per day.
Oh.
Um, the ritual.
The shadow.
Grants invisibility for 60 seconds.
The apprentice.
Mmm.
The lord is super good if you don't care about casting magic.
So far, I actually...
I've thought about that one because I...
Don't really care about casting magic.
Everything once per day is kind of meh.
Right, that's why I was like looking at something maybe like...
Oh, this one.
I was thinking either the warrior, the thief, the lord.
Not the apprentice.
Weakness to magic.
By a hundred percent?
Holy cow.
Luck boosts every skill in this game?
Oh!
Really?
Wait, what was the shadow?
Oh, the invisibility.
Wait, that's kind of huge, no?
You can change star signs really easily.
Oh, you can?
It's good.
Thief is good.
Let's try a thief.
I'm a thief.
Yes.
The signs I read show the end of my path.
My death, a necessary end.
He's flickering.
Will come when it will come.
You're okay, buddy.
What about me?
I'm so selfish.
Oh, you're gonna die, but what about me, huh?
You can't change star signs in Oblivion.
Oh, I got one guide.
Well, at least we picked...
A good one, I guess.
At least we picked a decent one.
So, it's okay.
I don't mind.
Your stars are not mine.
Today, the thief shall guide your steps on the road to destiny.
Yes.
Hmm, can you see my fate?
My dreams grant me no opinions of success.
Their compass ventures not beyond the doors of death, but in your face, I behold the sun's companion.
The dawn of Akatosh's bright glory may banish the coming darkness.
One chance to...
One last chance to add a character I end up to a door.
And with the promise of your aid, my heart must be satisfied.
Aren't you afraid to die?
No trophies of my triumphs precede me.
But I have lived well, and my ghost shall rest easy.
Men are but flesh and blood.
They know their doom, but not the hour.
In this, I am blessed to see the hour of my death.
To face my apportioned fate.
Then fall.
Okay.
Where are we going?
I won't spoil, but there's peak voice acting.
Like the...
I love that lady.
She's like, oh no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I go to my grave.
A tongue shriller than all the music calls me.
Where are we going?
You shall follow me yet for a while.
Then we must part.
Okay.
What if I kill you first?
Oh, my god.
Okay.
The blades.
We're the emperor's bodyguards.
Our job is to get him out of situations like this.
Although I admit, things are not going according to plan.
End him now.
My job is to make sure the emperor gets out of here alive, and I intend to do it.
Okay.
Stick close and let us do our job, and you'll be all right.
Do I need to have the torch, or...
Did you guys loot this place already?
I guess...
I guess I'll follow them.
No.
A little dip?
No?
Okay.
Not much fun.
This one's mine!
Oh.
Why are there bugs on my strings?
Prisoner, help!
I thought mud crabs were fearsome.
Ah!
Oh, my god.
That guy's on fire!
Everything good?
This one's mine.
Take their...
Take everything that they have.
Nothing.
Just their clothes.
Oblivion!
Protect the emperor!
Yeah!
Let's go down.
Watch your backwards.
That's the matter.
They don't need me.
Undress them.
Why are there so many guys down here?
Anyway.
The faceplate.
What if I went?
Everything's fine.
I could have told you.
I don't know, though.
I don't know about that.
This is gonna open up.
I don't know.
There's a door over there, too!
This is about to be an ambush.
Wait, you guys are going that way.
Wait, what's over here, then?
A trap!
What's it worth a try?
In there?
It's a dead end!
Oh, okay!
There's no good options here.
What, just open?
They're behind us.
Wait here, sire.
Oh my god!
Wait here with the emperor.
Guard him with your life.
Oh, me?
For the emperor!
Let's get...
They're just standing there.
I told you to stay with the emperor.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Let's get...
Okay, bye-bye.
I'll save it with the emperor.
Oblivion take you!
Yeah!
I...
There's nobody here!
Okay.
Oblivion take you.
I can go no further.
You alone must stand against the prince of destruction and his mortal servants.
He must not have the amulet of kings.
Okay.
Take the amulet.
Give it to Joffrey.
Joffrey.
He alone knows where to find my last son.
I don't know.
Who's Joffrey?
Are you about to die?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can't move!
Ah!
Stranger.
You chose a bad day to take up the coals of the...
Ah!
I couldn't move!
My sword for the dragon!
No.
Talos save us.
Oh, no.
It wasn't me.
We failed.
I failed.
Are you gonna...
Are you gonna kill yourself?
Blades are sworn to protect the emperor.
Now he and all his heirs are dead.
The amulet.
Where's the amulet of kings?
It wasn't on the emperor's body.
Do I have it?
The emperor gave it to me.
Strange.
He saw something in you.
Trusted you.
They say it's the dragon blood that flows through the veins of every septum.
They see more than less of them.
I think people...
I think he thinks I'm calming.
The amulet of kings is a sacred symbol of the empire.
I bring a wave of nostalgia to him.
Most people think of the red dragon crown.
Like an old movie.
But that's just jewelry.
The amulet has power.
Only a true heir of the blood can wear it, they say.
What if I am?
He must have given it to you for a reason.
Did he say why?
I'm not gonna tell you.
What if you are the one sending in all these guys in?
What if you...
I must take it to Joffrey.
Joffrey?
He said that?
Why?
There is another heir.
Nothing I ever heard about.
But Joffrey would be the one to know.
He's the Grand Master of my order.
Although you may not think so to meet him.
He lives quietly as a monk at Waynon Priory.
Near the city of Coral.
Coral.
How do I get there?
First, you need to get out of here.
Through that door must be the entrance to the sewers.
Past the locked gate.
That's where we were heading.
Okay.
It's a secret way out of the imperial city.
Or it was supposed to be secret.
Yeah.
Here, you'll need this key for the last door into the sewers.
Oh, thank you.
The sewers?
There are rats and goblins down there.
Ah, more!
But from what I've seen of you, I'm guessing you're an experienced pilgrim.
Am I right?
I'm more of an alien.
Well, you must now choose your class.
The major skills of your class will start higher than your other skills and will be easier to increase.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I could be a pilgrim!
Select a class or create a custom class.
What's a custom class?
Oh!
Interesting.
Custom.
Custom is good.
We are Japanese goblins.
You can even name it?
Wait.
Maybe stealth is good.
I like being stealthy.
Attributes.
What?
My personal...
Oh my god!
Nobody...
Only my mother would love me with that face!
Wow!
Bare hands.
How much you can carry.
I do...
I do think that's pretty good for me.
Willpower.
How much you regenerate.
Magical.
Greatly increases your maximum fatigue.
Hmm?
The agility...
I feel...
Oh!
Slightly increases your maximum fatigue.
The amount you deal with bows!
That's me!
Oh my gosh!
Look at the little snakey too!
Bows!
How fast you move.
Increases your maximum health.
Defines how quickly you regenerate health.
You need some personality.
Aye!
Custom otage class.
Fix all of your skills.
Oh yes!
Yeah!
So...
Hmm...
Stealth archer, baby.
Oh my god.
ET.
Luck is solid.
If it does everything!
I mean...
That's pretty good, no?
Hmm...
Fix how much people like you.
I kinda wanna...
ET has a good personality.
ET is like...
Luck is a bait, not luck.
Luck is bad.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Ugh!
I think ET should have a good personality.
Such a likable fellow.
Personality for the winning smile.
They are lying.
Well...
I...
I wasn't gonna pick luck anyway.
So...
It's fine.
Because I picked a...
Wait, did I pick it earlier?
I did the thief one.
I don't remember if that had luck on it.
Great personality.
No one needs personality.
Hehehehe.
Um...
Greatly increases your max health.
Snake has a likable personality.
No, he does not.
That guy is...
That guy is a grump.
Endurance for running and jumping?
That doesn't even say though.
If that's...
Endurance does not...
I feel like endurance would not not be like...
I feel like endurance would affect my fatigue, no?
But it doesn't.
It's better to be lucky than to be skilled in all things.
That's so true.
Lucky people are the worst.
I'm so jealous of lucky people.
Endurance equals carry more weight.
Wait, but why doesn't it say that then?
Endurance...
It just says endurance is HP.
It does not say anything about...
It doesn't say anything about...
Um...
How much you can carry or your fatigue.
Strength... Yeah, strength is carry weight.
He is lying.
I'm not getting one guide.
I'm correcting them.
I don't...
If I got one guide, I would follow what they said.
But I...
I'm correcting them.
To finish the game, I recommend to look up some Oblivion memes.
I've been watching some clips.
I like the silly things that happen.
I don't know.
Why do I feel like the second...
One is so difficult to choose?
Honestly, I feel like...
Well, I don't need the Magicka most likely.
Uh...
I kinda wanna just be able to...
I don't know.
Speed...
We could go so fast.
What weapon?
I probably will mostly use the bow and arrow.
So maybe having something with fatigue...
Well, this increases our fatigue a little bit.
So...
Agility was a must.
I feel.
Hmm...
Luck's biggest issue is it slows to improve by level ups.
You can only do plus one luck per level, but 60 luck improves all skills by plus four.
Oh, okay, okay.
I get it.
Hmm...
Speed for backpedaling while shooting.
That's good.
That's a good point.
Hmm...
Agility plus willpower.
That's what I was thinking because of the fatigue, huh?
Hmm...
I'm going with personality.
E.T.
is like the...
Greatest guy!
Combat!
Oh!
Um...
Uh...
Athletics.
Wow!
Effects how quickly...
Wait, these are major skills, so we can pick a couple, no?
How quickly we can run, swim, and sprint?
Hmm...
Oh...
Wait...
You can pick seven.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So...
Oh!
I see!
There's more!
Oh!
Well, I still think athletics is good.
Affects to jump higher and withstand falls.
Affects your ability to use light armor more effectively.
Oh!
Damage and deal with bows!
Affects your ability to get better deals when buying or selling.
Open locked doors and containers!
Sneak!
Move unseen and unheard.
Oh!
Speechcraft.
Affects your ability to persuade listeners to like and trust...
I already got a good personality.
I didn't even look at the magic.
Oh...
Blade.
Blunt.
Hand to hand.
CQC.
Heavy armor.
Speechcraft for NPC fun?
Oh!
Okay, I like that.
Light or heavy armor?
Yeah, I was thinking about getting an armor one, but...
Probably light armor would be best if I'm trying to keep things...
I didn't get any...
I'm not good with heavy stuff.
You know what I mean?
Light armor is for cowards?
What do you mean?
What do you mean cowards?
What do you like the look of more?
Probably...
I actually don't have a preference.
I like how I'm an elf, but I don't care about the magic.
E.T.
Wore a blanket.
That's light armor.
Good enough.
You convinced me.
No, and we'll do acrobatics.
That's me.
I am...
The E.T.T.
floor.
Didn't E.T.
wield magic?
It's not magic if he's...
If he's an alien.
That's just part of his...
All he knew how to do was glow his finger.
He didn't know how to do anything else.
He's an alien.
He was.
We are...
Katie...
Oh...
Perry.
Wait, get it?
Katy Perry.
That's the class name.
Yeah, I know.
It's the Katy Perry, get it?
You get it?
Because we're alien and...
Gosh, you guys...
You guys don't understand my genius.
Sometimes I see comments from people that are like...
Man, I...
Why is Mint always laughing?
What is she laughing at?
What does she find so funny?
I just laugh a lot.
I just laugh at everything.
And also, I'm a nervous laugher.
I'm an angry laugher.
I'm an awkward laugher.
I'm a sad laugher.
I just laugh at everything.
I can't take anything seriously, maybe.
I'm not allowed to laugh in 2025.
I'm just always laughing at whatever.
Because it's always...
I can always just see how any little tiny thing can be so funny.
Like the way this...
Like the way this chameleon looks.
Or the way that these two guys are standing.
You've been extra laughy today.
Am I?
I can't tell.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um...
I was gonna do like E, T, E, but...
That...
We're not combat either.
We're stealth.
Don't take meds.
Be happy.
You and Doki just laugh at everything then.
Yeah, pretty much.
What's wrong with E, T?
Sneaky T?
Hmm.
Yeah!
Create the Sneaky T class?
Yes.
I am Sneaky T.
Yeah.
I wasn't far off.
In any case, rats and goblins won't give you any trouble.
It's neat.
Up to the sewers, then what?
You must get the amulet to Joffrey.
Who the hell is Joffrey?
Take no chances, but proceed to Wayne in Priory immediately.
Got it?
Got it.
I understand.
No, please explain more.
Take it easy.
You'll be fine.
I know this is a lot to take in all at once.
Yeah, you think?
No one's more surprised than me that I'm sending an escaped prisoner off with the amulet of kings.
What do you mean escaped?
You let me out!
But the emperor trusted you for a reason.
And I trust the emperor.
The amulet of kings must get to Joffrey at Wayne in Priory.
Sneety phone hole.
Joffrey should know how to find the heir the emperor spoke of.
The amulet must reach Emperor Uriel's heir, so a new emperor can be crowned.
Okay.
What about you?
I'll stay here to guard the emperor's body and make sure no one follows you.
Okay.
Can I loot the emperor or...?
May Talos guide you.
Okay.
By the way, thanks for recovering Captain Renault's sword.
I'll see that it is given a place of honor in the halls of the blades.
Wait, are you taking my sword?
Don't do that.
Leave the emperor in peace.
Did he just take my sword?
He did!
You son of a bitch.
Well, good thing we invested everything into bow and arrow, I guess.
Oh my god!
Why did you take my thing?
Oh no, this guy died too!
He didn't notice.
Take it back.
Oh, he doesn't have it.
Oh my god.
What's...
What are you doing?
We're fine!
What's wrong?
I'll...
Okay.
I'll go now.
I didn't take anything from you though.
Kill him and take the sword.
He didn't have it.
He knows what you're thinking.
Clearly.
All right.
We're sneaky.
We're sneet.
Take his pants.
By the only one who thinks Minto said...
She can loot the...
No!
It's not what I said at all.
Okay, what if I...
Very easy.
What if I...
Okay, what if I F5...
And then I do it.
Okay, let's try it now.
Oh.
It won't let me anymore.
Oh, hi.
Is it because I...
Oh, put away the bow?
Don't mind me.
Okay, we'll wait.
We'll wait him to...
For him to not pay attention anymore.
All right.
Oh, you can only try once.
Oh, Boris has already caught you!
Oh.
Okay.
Fine.
Um...
Oh.
See the sewers!
Already caught.
Autosave.
The rats and the goblins.
The rats and the goblins!
Okay.
What a thrill.
Heading in there.
Oh gosh.
We're gonna be so disgusting.
Can't believe he wouldn't let me take stuff from the emperor's pockets.
Who's gonna...
He doesn't need them anymore.
No?
What the?
Who are you trying to impress?
I hear something walking, but I don't know what it is.
All right.
Let's get him.
Dang!
Let's go!
One shot kill?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, baby.
We're too...
Oh my god.
Cheese!
I'm gonna be heavy though.
No, I'm not.
Just kidding.
Flattered crate.
Flour.
I'm gonna become a baker.
Nevermind.
It was too much.
It was too much!
Eat the cheese!
So good.
Oop.
That rat just hopped.
Is he eating the body, I think?
Oop.
Dang.
Uh...
Let's see.
Wait.
I wanna...
Uh-oh.
Wasabi.
Wasabi!
Oh, stinking rat.
Um, I forgot...
I want to put something in our quick...
You know, under number two.
We'll just put the axe, I guess.
No.
The sword is better.
Nah, we'll...
Add cheese.
More cheese.
Less macaroni.
The sword is better.
I don't even know if we should keep the...
Oh.
Stupid.
Dummy dumb.
Idiot.
Short sword or dagger?
This is a short sword.
Sneak.
Up sneak.
So many bugs.
Matarikon.
Wow, they actually...
Scatter.
That's kind of...
A fun...
Detail.
Is there any point in swimming in there?
Maybe if I want to get diseased?
If I want diseases, I should go in, huh?
See, you got...
Garlic!
Wow.
A real...
A real chef over here.
Guy was...
He was one day away from opening his own restaurant.
Then I killed him.
Activate?
The gate is sealed.
Oh, okay.
Phew.
Uh-oh.
Stinky.
Garlic is like the one thing I will...
Be like, you know what?
Worth?
Worth the smell.
I'll eat garlic for...
I'm a garlic girl.
I don't care if I stink.
After I eat garlic.
It's tasty.
I keep doing right click to like...
To like...
Snipe, you know?
Garlic gang.
Yeah!
Ever had pickled garlic?
I don't think so, actually.
Who's in here?
This looks mighty suspicious.
Like an ambush.
No?
Nothing?
Wait, this gate?
Click save?
Okay.
You can zoom in with higher bow skills.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
This is not a door.
Is this gonna open?
It's sealed.
Okay, I guess we're safe.
Yippee!
Oh!
So they're kind of just like...
Oh, if you didn't like how you played, you can...
So someone did say that you could edit it here.
Last chance.
I think we're good.
I think we're good, guys.
Choose serpent.
No!
Don't tell me what to do!
I like what I have.
Good spot for a permanent save.
Oh, that's true.
Wait.
I did just...
Oh, wait.
It won't let me, like, get out of this.
Didn't I...
Um...
I did do a quick save.
Aw, man.
Escape?
Nah, it doesn't work.
If I click this...
Oh.
Well...
We're committed.
We're committed!
I could F9.
E-Tina.
Level 1.
Yeah, I could reload the auto.
No?
Wait.
Uh...
Hello?
What's happening?
Guys, I'm not moving.
Guys, this is not me.
Guys?
I...
My hand is off.
Guys, my game is glitched.
Guys, this is not me!
Haha.
Save game.
New save.
Oh, wait.
It only got all...
Look at these.
I guess these are...
These will...
Probably...
Be overwritten though, no?
No way.
We're finally playing the game.
What are you talking about?
This is my first time playing.
Let me...
Let me take my time.
Okay.
And I'm not glitched this time.
Wow.
The sunlight.
Oh, my eyes.
Wow.
It's a beautiful day.
Oh!
Whose house is that?
Oh.
Oh, wow.
We're out of the...
Oh.
The red arrow on your compass shows the direction of Wayne and Priory.
That's your house?
No.
Not beating the elf allegation.
I'm E.T.
What are you talking about?
You can walk there by following your compass or open your world map to travel there directly.
Or you can set off in any direction and begin exploring the world on your own.
Good luck!
The world on my own.
I can smell the grass.
And...
Look at the butterflies.
I can eat the butterflies!
I can just walk!
Wait.
Which way?
Oh, we do need to go that way.
But what's over here?
Oops.
I did not mean to press that.
I'm intense.
We get the phone home?
Is that a fish?
What the hell is that?
Slatter fish!
Dang, this thing is... tough.
Oh, it's dead.
Scales.
Why is it so tough?
It didn't even do anything.
Is he supposed to be... like, you know... spooky?
Oh!
Clearly, they're just... so...
They're friends, right?
They're so used to getting slaughtered.
Oh my gosh.
I'm... I'm... I'm... Oh no!
The game is too... The game is too powerful for me.
I'm lagging!
Give me a second.
I'm gonna... Change just a few settings, maybe.
Lock frame rate.
I already did that.
Wait.
Yeah.
I
don't want to change the quality distance... or, like, quality level, but... Hmm.
Imagining E.T.
running around with balled up fists going...
Uh... Water reflections off.
We could do that.
I'll change some things to... High instead of Ultra.
Things that, like, don't really matter.
You know what I mean?
Wait.
Does V-Sync... Should that be on or off?
I can't ever remember.
Off.
Okay.
I already had it off.
View distance will change that, too.
I think that'll also help a lot.
Oh, wait.
Confirm.
Okay.
Let's see.
Ah, buh, buh.
Oh.
Hey!
That helps him.
What the?
Oh!
Excuse me!
You came after me first!
Uh... Sorry.
Sorry.
You came after me first.
Self-defense.
Oh!
I swear!
Gosh, the game is so slow to load now.
You came after me first!
It was self-defense!
I swear!
You brought her!
You brought her.
Take all your arrows.
Ooh!
Boots!
What the fur?
Got the hole.
This is three.
What am I wearing?
Do I want to look like a bandit, though?
The breaches.
You ran into their camp with no warning.
I was not carrying weapons.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Don't even say that.
I totally had my bow in air.
I had my fists up.
But I had no weapons equipped.
You can check the VOD.
You can.
And a plate.
Wow, I can really just take everything in this game, huh?
This is on camera.
Oh, my athletics increased.
Spooked me for a second.
Lettuce and onion and onion.
What is this?
Where am I?
What's my FOV?
I have no idea.
A dungeon?
Wait.
Are you a friend?
Huh?
That's why I'm asking you.
Are you a friend?
Hello?
Who's there?
Me?
Should I be here?
Where are you?
Are you talking to me?
How do you hear me?
Hello?
Friend?
Buddy?
Are you a pal?
Whatever it was is gone now.
Sorry.
Oh, he's a bandit.
He's not.
Oh, whatever it is is gone now.
Yeah.
You.
Some torches.
Those are easy to take.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I just.
I just walked into that.
Oops.
Okay.
There's traps.
Got it.
Understood.
Oh my gosh.
Anything else over here?
No.
Friend?
No friends.
We could be.
Everybody could be a friend.
They just.
Choose.
You think?
What do you think?
Oh, whoops.
Can I take that back?
Thank you.
What are you sitting there for?
We got a big old sack.
Of food.
Yummy.
You guys see that?
Wait.
How can I?
Um.
How can I disable the trap?
Oh.
Wait.
Activate.
Wow.
That was pretty anti-climactic knoll.
That was so anti-climactic.
It just dropped.
Like nothing.
Alright.
Let's keep going.
Is that my shadow?
Oh.
That's those.
Okay.
How big is this?
This place is humongous.
What's the...
What am I supposed to find in here?
Big treasure?
Am I gonna become rich?
It's called puberty?
The balls dropped.
Junk.
This is gonna be more than junk.
It's gonna be...
Good junk.
Well, maybe good is a...
I hear something over...
Wait.
Is that a person?
Right there?
I think I see a person right there.
Got him?
Didn't even notice a thing?
I think it's very funny that they don't even notice that they're friends.
Something's like whispering behind me.
Their friends are dying.
99 plus arrows.
I got 99 arrows and a...
I killed a cat!
Kill me.
I'm so sorry!
Stone picture.
Flower.
There you are.
You got any gold on you?
Moss pick.
More arrows.
My sneak increase.
We love that brush.
Yeah, baby.
I thought you liked cats.
It's not my fault.
It's not me.
I promise.
It's kind of messed up that the gold costs my... It weighs you down.
Because it's like... Because it's like... Oh, wait.
No, it doesn't.
Oh, I was gonna say.
It discourages you from becoming rich and awesome.
I thought I did.
I thought I... I miss... I miss... Saw.
Zero weight.
No, that's my fault.
Wait, what's this for?
What does that do?
And it rolls?
Whoa.
Holy cow.
I forgot.
I think I got a jump buff.
No?
It's a puzzle.
Is it?
Is it actually?
Nobody will live.
No.
Oh.
You guys can't just tell me anything.
I'm gonna believe it.
It's my first time playing.
I'll believe you.
Oh, I'm over-encumbered.
Let's eat some food.
Let's eat...
Cheese wedge.
And...
Apple.
Wait, what am I wearing?
This.
That's three armor.
Tina looking sharp, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Drop half my arrows.
No!
They are...
0.1.
What do you mean I need to drop half of them?
It's 0.1.
They weigh nothing.
No, I could drop this axe.
Okay.
Bonk.
Oh, eat?
Oh.
Um...
Well...
It's... fine.
Probably.
Whatever.
Wait.
There's his awesome three.
Does he use them up?
Yeah, exactly.
Nothing.
Hold on.
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm in trouble.
I got him.
The ringleader.
He's got a fur helmet.
Easy.
Easy peasy, baby.
What do you got?
More arrows.
It's so hard not taking them.
Is anyone else down here?
Probably not, right?
What you got over here?
Oh, is that the prize?
A carrot.
I love carrots.
Take your sack.
Bane of being an archer.
I don't know.
I've been pretty successful so far.
Brief history of the empire.
Part four.
Oh, I'm gonna... spoilers.
Hold on.
Trank shooting from M.G.S.
Pit off.
Nah, hold on.
I'll come back here.
I'll come back.
It's another area of the dungeon?
Wait, actually?
No more apples.
Hold on.
Let's go to the other side.
This place is humongous.
Wait, so if I leave, will they regenerate?
There's another question I have.
I don't even... oh, wait.
I came from here.
No?
Oh, so, like, I'll have...
conquered it?
Or...
There will be actually no one else?
Nobody... no one else cares?
Oh, they're asleep here.
Is anybody asleep?
Nope.
No sleepy bandits?
This thing is so cool.
I want all of them.
Dirty scroll.
Some of the men were worried about these old ruins being haunted.
But Mephala take them.
This spot's going to be perfect for ambush merchants along the road.
And all under the nose of the Imperial Legion.
Finally got some of those big blue stones down today.
Berenice got the idea to shoot them down with her bow.
Got them all here with me.
I don't know what they are, but they stink of magicka.
Bet they'll fetch a nice price with the mages' guild.
Two coins and that Khajiit from...
Uh, what was it?
War...
Warden...
Warden Fow...
Set up their camps down the road.
Fine by me.
Spares the rest of us the smell.
Two coins ran up today.
Two coins?
That's their name?
Warden Fow...
Oh, it's not a W.
Oh.
Oh, ran up today.
The Khajiit's gone missing.
Swore to the nine that you could hear claws scrabbling at limestone, but nothing's down there.
I'm guessing she got tired of the smell and snuck out overnight.
Two coins of stench could peel shells off mud crabs.
I'm surprised she hung around that long.
Okay.
Ink.
I could go to sleep?
I could just...
I could just sleep?
Goodnight?
Corn!
Wow, they have so much food in here.
Is food, like, really important in this game?
A quick nap.
Wait, I have to sleep?
You have to sleep to level up.
Oh, so should I?
Not unless you do alchemy.
Ah, okay, okay.
Oh, yeah, I don't need to...
What is it gonna tell me, like, when I need to sleep?
Like, hey, buddy.
You are...
Tired.
You need...
Take, like...
You need to take five.
Yeah, it pops up?
Okay.
Iron.
Iron boots.
Whoa, claymore.
Green robe hood.
What if it looks good on me?
Icon in top right corner.
When level up is ready.
Ah, okay, okay.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Top left corner.
Top corner.
A corner.
Sorry, but with that face, nothing looks good.
Are you...
Are you saying I'm...
Ugly?
Are you...
Are you saying I'm ugly?
I'm ugly.
My mama made me like this.
You're insulting my mother.
Auto save.
Oh my gosh.
Where's the prize?
Oh my god, this place really is huge.
Holy cannoli.
Um...
Death penalty.
Two arms!
Two arms.
Sorry.
Yeah, I got two arms.
I've also got two eyes.
Weak potion of catastrophe.
Drain luck on self.
Why do you have that?
Two arms.
Two legs.
Two feet.
Oh, is that a person?
No, I think it's candles.
Yeah, it's candles.
I think they would have noticed, no?
Okay.
I keep hearing like a... And I can't tell if it's ambiance or something spooking me, you know?
Sorry.
Two arms.
Maybe that's her name.
Like two coins?
We got two arms.
And... Um... She's like a Pokemon.
It's just the ghosts.
She's like a Pokemon.
Yells her name out.
But what if you lose an arm?
It's like an identity crisis.
I love how I'm just crouch-walking this entire game.
That looks like a trap, no?
Oh.
Maybe it was... Oh.
Secret tunnel.
Two arms.
Oh.
I didn't do that.
Uh-oh.
Who's taking... Who's stealing my kills?
That's... That's stealing my kills.
Oh.
Dang it.
That was... That was unfortunate.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Dang it.
He's fast.
Oh.
Goodness gracious.
I don't think you can shoot.
Can you?
I'll take my arrows back.
I'm a zombie now?
No.
Crouch-walk equals lore accurate.
I know.
It's...
Not that.
No.
That's not true.
But, um...
It's just...
They get the screen like all dark and everything.
It's just kind of funny.
Oh.
These are so pretty.
Zombo.
Oh, wait.
We, like, avoided...
A whole big area.
Um...
What are you doing here, anyway?
Dead bandit?
Okay.
Is this, like, a secret room, or...
Oh, wait.
This one opened?
Wait.
That one opened.
She had more arrows.
She had non-rusty arrows.
Wait.
Actually...
There's a difference?
I haven't noticed.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll go back.
Iron arrow.
Wait, bow?
Oh!
Because I have a rusty bow.
Oh, and she has a better bow.
I was going to say.
The iron's that good.
Or the...
The arrow's that good?
Um, and then...
And then...
You.
Okay.
Nice.
Thank you, guys.
Good...
Good notice.
We gaming?
Yeah.
Thanks to you guys.
Hehe.
I wouldn't have noticed.
More zombo?
Yep.
Let's test out our new...
Oh, nice.
That big damage.
Oh, sh...
Oh, I got him.
Big damage.
Why are there zombies in here?
They're freaking me out.
Whoa.
Do I need to put that up there?
Ah!
Just kidding.
The treasure room.
Please.
Oh, this is a chest.
Oh.
Weak potion of charisma.
What do you mean?
I lose personality.
I'm so charismatic.
Is that a skelly?
Riz potion.
Oh, I see him.
I don't...
Definitely don't think that was a headshot.
The first one, at least.
Oh, it's just water.
Anybody else in here?
It's so dark.
Oh, there's more.
Bone meal.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
I can go in here.
Dodge.
There's...
There's a whole passageway.
There's a whole passageway down there, you guys.
I don't think we can make it, though.
I don't think we can make it, because...
I don't have enough.
You could try.
You can?
I can.
I'll quick save.
All right, here we go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
We managed to avoid drowning.
Back to sneak.
I kind of miss the humans.
Or not humans, but you know.
Wait.
I'm so lost in here now, you guys.
Ow,
what the hell?
What the?
Uh-oh.
What
the hell?
Uh-oh.
Maybe I don't understand how lockpicking works.
Maybe I don't understand.
Oh.
Maybe I do understand how lockpicking works.
Is this the room we were in before?
Yeah.
We're through... yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So we went...
A long ways away.
First try?
Probably?
Okay.
I know there was that other area.
Are these all doors?
Is that a skelly in there?
Oh!
There's a skelly in there!
Safe?
Yeah.
Wait.
I haven't checked my map.
And well, um... I don't have a map of this area.
Dorigo, thank you so much for the tiny gift that I give you.
What if I...
Can I get you through the hole?
Let's try.
Through the hole.
Where'd that go?
There's one!
Wait, this is a dungeon.
This is their prison.
Oh, nevermind.
They sure are pretty.
That really is their prison.
Do you have anything in there?
There's no point in going in, no?
Free the sca... Oh, hi.
Sorry.
Free the sca... No.
Alright, let's go to that other room.
So jumpy.
Oh, he must be new here.
He must be new here.
Could be hidden treasure.
I hear a guy.
Wow!
That's like the most obvious trap I've ever seen.
Where is he?
I missed her.
Um... Which one should I not step on?
Uh... Which one should I... Where should I not step?
This one?
I hear him.
I hear him over there.
All the blue stones can be looted?
Yeah, I didn't know that.
Oh.
I think I can... Oh.
Uh, wait.
Wait.
I'm going.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah, I didn't want to take so many because they're...
But they... They do... They do sell for a pretty penny, huh?
I didn't want to get over encumbered, but...
I guess... It'd be good to take more of them, huh?
You're pretty good.
Thanks.
I like sniping.
Oh.
I say as I... You know.
Oh, shoot.
That wasn't as good.
Ah!
Crap!
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Take your stone.
I take your stone.
Whose... Whose... Whose grave is this?
Doesn't matter.
I take your stone.
Oh!
I'm too good of a jumper.
Oh, God!
I'm the best jumper ever!
Wait!
This is what they meant by increased?
I'm over encumbered.
I saw some people say that I can...
Oh!
I see.
If I zoom in...
Let's see.
What do we want to get rid of?
We love acrobatics.
There's an amulet!
I could sell it for a thousand gold, though, you guys.
Pretty tempting!
Oh, that looks horrible.
God, I can't get over how much it looks like...
Actually!
I was gonna say, I can't believe how much it looks like E.T.
But, you know what?
I think I'm kind of seeing the Crypt Keeper.
Drop the shield.
Yeah, we can get rid of the shield.
I think I'm seeing the Crypt Keeper.
Give me my arrows back.
My arrow.
Oh, okay.
We came from here.
Or...
Yes.
Yes?
Oh.
Thought someone saw me.
Do-do-do-do.
Ruh-ruh!
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna die.
Where is he?
I heard him.
Ruh-roh!
Oh.
Didn't realize that was a wall.
Where is he?
Is there anybody in there?
Hello?
Oh.
Like, Zoic Scoob.
That don't look so good.
Actually, that blood is like so fresh.
The blood is so fresh in the boat.
They decompose at the speed of light.
I'm hearing whispers.
I'm going crazy.
I'm going so crazy.
Hard!
Okay.
All right.
Let's, um...
Figure this out, huh?
Wait.
Who?
Where?
Oh.
Whomst?
Where?
Uh.
Yep.
Yeah!
Uh-uh-duh-duh.
Uh.
K.
Somebody's here.
They're gonna...
Attack.
Somebody's...
Red dot.
The red dot.
Must be the wind.
Um, let's see.
Oh
my god.
I think I messed up, you guys.
I think I messed up.
Ah!
Where are you?
There you go.
Ah!
Take that!
Oh.
Oops.
I'm blocked in.
I'm looping him.
Ouch.
I didn't loop them.
I didn't loop them at all.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
I'm gonna die.
Just kidding.
It is you.
Why are you so strong for a skeleton?
Run!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Just one more hit.
We're fine.
I shouldn't press buttons willy-nilly.
I think.
My heal.
What's this?
Oh.
I'll take them.
Who sees me, though?
It must be the guys behind the walls.
I imagine.
I think I...
I can't remember...
Uh, three.
Three.
Just get rid of that, and then three.
Three?
Oh, wait.
Do I see?
Okay.
Where...
Did that do anything?
Oh, like the tiniest amount.
But you...
But I think...
Because we're still technically in battle...
I won't...
Regen health, huh?
Is...
What I think is the case?
Get stronger as you level it up.
Okay.
Oh, just slowly.
Oh, yeah.
I can actually see it a little bit.
Okay.
Um...
Do I just like...
Get all these in?
Okay, I won't press all of them at once.
I'll press them one at a time.
So that, you know...
Ah, damn.
Oh, where'd he go?
It's so dark in there.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
Wrong block.
Wrong one.
This one.
See, and now...
They don't know I'm here.
Wait.
Where's the opening?
Where the hell is this guy?
Mister?
What are you doing in the corner?
Oh, yeah.
Where is he?
That's the guy I killed, no?
Maybe I was never ever supposed to open these.
It's empty.
Who killed you?
Who...
He died...
Of boredom...
Waiting for somebody.
I also saw this here.
A key...
Check the other room for coffins.
I guess we...
Oh, wait.
Did I get this one?
Yeah.
Oh, this one has one too.
Okay.
Maybe...
More potion of heal...
Oh, not bad.
More potion of healing will take it.
Okey-dokey.
Oh!
Maybe this is what opened up.
I see.
Oh, so...
I just messed up.
I should have...
I only needed the one key.
Literally.
Is this the treasure room?
This is the treasure room.
This is the treasure room!
Literally, the last door that I did...
In the puzzle...
Was the one that I needed.
The only thing.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Still Skelly's guarding the place.
Give me the...
Oh, shoot.
Woo!
Yeah, take that.
I don't know how I knocked your...
Your feet off.
I knocked him off his feet!
Varvla stone cage activate.
Is there anything...
Wait, is this a tunnel way?
I feel like I am...
Playing...
Half-Life with how much...
I am quick saving.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ugh!
This cage is raised remotely.
This?
No?
Which way?
This is the large...
This is the hugest dungeon ever.
Button upstairs.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what I figured.
I didn't know if there was like...
Other doorways.
That's just why I was looking around.
Ah!
But before we do that...
See if anybody's in here.
No way.
Oh my god!
There's more!
Sancremati.
Let's see.
Okie dokie.
Beep!
That looks valuable.
Did it open anything else?
Any other skellies behind doors?
The treasure!
I'm sorry, this is worth as much as the... the... as much as the amulet given to me by the king?!
Valuable, baby.
Money, money, money, money.
It pays to steal!
Freedom?
Bada-boom, baby.
Bada-bing, bada-boom, baby.
Oh, there's a lot of whispers happening now.
Oh, oh, oh!
Did I do that?
We can do this easy.
Am I in between?
Actually, I can just run.
Oh my gosh!
Statue.
That's cool.
I'm over encumbered again.
I've got too much loot.
Let's...
Gotta eat more...
You guys, we gotta...
We gotta...
We gotta eat stuff.
Cheese!
Corn!
Chomp, chomp, chomp!
The...
This armor's not gonna fit...
Fit us by the end of the...
This...
The garlic weighs literally nothing.
Lettuce!
Why is the lettuce so heavy?
Oh my goodness, which way do I go?
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Bear pelt is useless, is it?
I'll get rid of it.
Well, I don't wanna get...
Hold on.
I don't wanna get one guide.
Is it useless, you guys?
Heavy lettuce.
Gotta find a merchant soon.
I know, right?
Sort by weight.
My iron grieves.
Our grievance.
Toss it.
It's worth the irony.
Why do you look like E.T.?
Cuz I am E.T.
Hello.
Please meet E.Tina.
Please...
Meet your...
It's your number one extraterrestrial gal.
E.Tina.
Okay, I'll get rid of the bear pelt.
And we'll go...
If you're going in a maze, go left.
Oh my gosh!
I went the wrong way.
Look at their little...
caskets.
No.
Nothing.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Okay, this way.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Wait!
This might be an exit?
Actually, hold on.
I wanna check the other side too, though.
I wanna check this side too, though.
Oh, it's a door.
Easy gate.
We haven't been in here before.
Oh, I should've done it there.
I don't think I understand it.
Oh!
I got it.
Oh, I think...
Oh, what I'm hearing is the...
swinging.
I thought I was hearing something, like...
making noise.
Or like a...
You know, a little guy, but...
Okay, well there's just this in here.
And it's more potions.
But if I take them, I'll be...
So this one really had nothing.
Well, they both had nothing, I guess.
Okay.
Run, run, run.
And you...
And up we go.
All right.
You think it's a friend?
They're not dressed like the others.
Hi.
It's never a friend.
Guess it was nothing.
Okay.
Now we have to deal with men!
Skellies!
Oh my gosh, he's got a little bed.
Wait, what are you?
Jowbert!
Uh oh.
I think this was a real person, you guys.
Necromancer!
He's got a dark shirt.
Wide pants.
Copper ring.
I'll take that.
What are you doing here?
You necromancer!
Are you...
Necromancer sack?
What you got in there?
Got some flesh and bones.
Okay.
Uh...
I'll take that.
And that.
Necromancy may be legal in...
Ca...
Caр...
Caro-dil.
But few will openly admit to practicing it now that it's been banned by the mages' guild.
Oh, it's been banned.
Manual!
Wait, let's see.
The beginning spellcaster.
The most powerful mages in Tamriel were once beginners.
They all had similar early experiences.
Don't beat yourself up on the lockpicking minigame is rough.
No, it's okay.
I'm gonna become a pro.
The mages guild of Tamriel have long been the first stop on a long road to knowledge and power for many individuals, providing magical services for the general public.
Oh, mucho texto.
Guild... oh.
The guild offers a wide variety of spells for purchase and is recommended as a first stop for any...
I'm not gonna be a spellcaster though.
Maybe.
Probably not.
What if I decide I have a change of heart like mid...
Mid game.
And I just want to start chucking fireballs at everybody.
I do.
I should have thrown those fireballs before.
I should have gotten a taste of it.
You know?
You can do that.
You can.
Man.
I'm not stuck to being an archer forever.
The sword.
Yeah, but it's a long sword.
I don't know if I want to take it.
This one right here.
You good?
I can always sell it.
But it's heavy.
Sorry.
I will be coming cumbered.
It's fine.
Heart gate.
Wait a second.
I think I know this.
Oh gosh.
Can I...
Okay, I can get out.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe we can find a key somewhere.
Does he have a key?
Do you have a key?
I didn't see a key.
No.
There is a key.
Yeah, I just gotta find it.
Swear.
Swear it.
I imagine it's like up there.
Wait, can I get up here?
Oh my gosh.
I'm a master jumper.
Of course I can.
Parkour.
Jump.
For the key.
For the beef.
Where the hell am I?
Where does this go?
Stone door to...
Vilvorin.
Is that...
Is Vilvorin another word for exit?
Look.
Wait a second.
Would this just...
Actually, I'm kinda confused.
What the map is showing me.
It looks like it's just a loop, but...
That's not...
That's not the case, right?
This is the door I skipped?
No way.
Oh my gosh!
It really is!
I thought...
I thought it was...
The area where like the...
The bandit leader was.
That I...
That I killed.
With the two guys.
I thought it was that area.
Oh my god.
I was like, there's no way it's a loop.
It was indeed a loop.
Oh god.
Someday...
Someday we'll see the sun again.
I'm...
I'm doomed...
To a life of sewers and dungeons.
I don't think I need...
How many do I have on these potions anyway?
I think I have quite many.
No?
Oh!
This is the way out!
Wait, what's this?
No.
We went there.
We went everywhere.
We've been everywhere!
Oh my gosh.
Is it really?
Oh my god!
That's the trap I activated!
And I didn't realize...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
And that's the guy I killed!
That thought he was a friend, but he wasn't!
Oh!
The
freeze!
Sweet freedom!
It's purple outside.
What the hell is that?
Is that one of them crabs we're talking about?
Dang.
It's further than I thought it was.
It's dinner.
That's what it is.
Crab on me!
Mud crab.
Are these delicious?
Why does it have a lockpick?
Dinner.
Ah!
Oh my god!
They're violent!
Where the hell did you come from?
Sneaky crab!
Oh my god!
Seeking your roots.
I've recovered a sprig of Nern root.
What?
I dropped my house keys back there.
Oh.
Good luck.
Alright.
Good luck for you.
A plant ingredient.
This unusual must have value.
Bring it to a chemist.
Oh.
Nern...
Nern root quest.
The nerd root.
Before...
Oh!
The sun is coming up.
It's a beautiful day.
I've escaped the dungeons.
A horse!
Wait.
That horse has a...
person.
But what if I won it instead?
Um...
Excuse me.
Just kidding.
Uh...
Can I have your horse?
Good evening.
Day?
What day is it?
Can you tell me what day it is?
Hello, sir.
Yeah, what day is it?
Rumors.
There's been some terrible trouble at the chapel in Anvil.
All of the Bella's priests and priestesses murdered.
Murdered.
Carry on.
Okay.
Look at this horse.
I'll become encumbered though, no?
Take his horse.
I kinda really want it.
I hear some...
Oh, I think I hear the little root shining.
I hear like a...
Bring!
Take his pants!
What if I just...
Take my ear, sir, sir.
Oh.
I already asked you.
I'm ready...
I'm ready to...
Or...
Rather...
I'm not quite ready to...
Become such a nuisance to the world yet.
But soon...
Take his life.
You guys are so hungry for...
For blood.
I'm just here to explore...
Just a little bit.
Before I then start taking lives.
You know?
Oh, there's another guy.
Chained in hall.
Hello, sir.
My athletics.
Level 27.
Yeah.
Talk to me.
Talk, talk, talk.
You got any rumors?
What's the tea?
Find divine.
Stay on the roads.
The wilderness just isn't safe anymore.
We've had sightings, you see.
The Daedra.
The Daedra?
Move along.
Okay.
How do I put my fists away?
I don't think I can, you guys.
YouTube is acting...
Oh, YouTube!
Oh my gosh.
It's been so bad.
Anytime I watch people's streams lately, it's just...
It's always buffering.
It's not great at all.
I'm so sorry.
Fort Eurosec.
Yeah, but like...
That guy...
Oops.
Oh, F to sheath your fists.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Nice shot.
Hey.
I don't need your sass.
It was a nice shot if I was trying to...
Miss.
If I was trying to get...
I was just trying to scare him.
You know?
I was just trying to get right in between them.
I gotta go find a...
A guy to...
Sell all my stuff to.
I think that should be our priority number one.
Why...
Why is everything trying to kill me?
What are you?
Oh my god, there's rats out here too!
I thought it was like a possum or something.
Okay, I'm not putting my weapon away.
That was a bad idea.
He did just tell me not to go off the roads.
But...
I...
Uh oh.
Something's on fire.
Oh, that's the campsite.
Rats are everywhere.
Nice.
Whee!
Um...
If I walk around with my bow and arrow out...
Will people get angry at me?
Will they be like...
Hey...
Hey buddy.
Why are you so aggressive?
Why are you coming at me like that?
No?
Aw, the little deer!
Oh my god, so cute.
Bambi.
Yes, sorta.
Oh my god, not a freaking crab.
Stay away from me!
Stay away from me, crab!
Knock him over.
I was just coming to see what this was.
Looked fancy.
Way shrine stendar.
Protect the weak.
Pray at my chapel altars to receive my blessings.
Oh!
What did I get?
Oh, thank you!
A buff?
Let's go.
Imperial city is the walls and tower to the west.
Uh...
This right there, right?
Yeah, I did notice it.
I think, uh...
Probably would be...
Best to just go there, huh?
Cause it's so close.
I'm gonna go back to the...
This thing.
And...
Oh wait, I swam across, didn't I?
We can swim here!
Why are the deer not doing anything?
They're kinda freaking me out.
Oh, I hear a quest.
I hear a quest!
Is it you?
Oh!
It's the Nern Root!
Hahahaha!
They're very tranquil, you guys.
They're very...
Don't they just kind of put you at ease?
Oop!
Trick shot!
I'm not gonna shoot them!
I only shoot...
Oop!
I shoot to kill.
And I'm not hungry right now.
Yeah, so serene.
Until a damn mud crab comes at you.
Ooh, it's...
My game's lagging just a tad sometimes, but...
Who's attacking me?
Oh my god!
What the hell are you?!
Oh!
That's like a real enemy!
I thought it was a damn crab!
What the hell?!
Is there another?
Ah!
Oh my god, it was a crab!
Oh my god, there are crabs here too.
They were working together!
Oh my god!
Leave me alone!
It was an ambush!
Push!
I'm on the path!
Everybody leave me alone!
I am...
I am but a weary traveler!
I've gone through so much!
They hurt you!
Wow, this game really is pretty though!
Wow!
By nine divines, stay on the road!
Yes, officer!
I am an elf of the law!
An alien elf!
I guess this counts as the road, huh?
Yeah.
Oh, I'm at the prison.
I mean... They won't, like, lock me back up, will they?
Will they be like... Hey, we remember you.
Back to the cell.
Just visiting.
I like how it's the Oblivion logo.
They can and will!
No!
I've done no!
I'm... I'm E-Tina!
I'm literally... Oh.
I'm a local celeb at this point.
Can you spare a coin?
Oh.
I'm lagging again.
Hold on.
Oof.
Let's see.
Yeah, I might change the resolution.
Other... But it's, like, it's so small for me, otherwise.
V-Sync on?
Oh, you can try it.
I think that works.
Actually.
Code of 480p.
Yeah, baby.
Put a frame limit.
I already did that.
Thank you, though.
E-T!
One man's trash soon becomes another man's trash, I suppose.
Hello.
Uh...
Rumors?
There's been some terrible trouble at the chapel in Anvil.
All of the Bella's priests and priestesses murdered.
Murdered.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to... Also, there we go.
Noise.
Stop right there, criminal maid.
Nobody breaks the law on my watch.
I'm taking your stolen goods.
Now pay the fine or it's off to jail with you.
No, you can't.
What are you looking for?
You can't.
You can't rest me.
I'm already... I already quit.
Where can I sleep?
Merchants Inn in the market.
King and Queen in Elven Gardens.
The Tiber Septim in Talos Plaza.
And All Saints in Temple District.
There's also the bloated float on the waterfront, but...
Okay.
Farewell, citizen.
I've heard others say the same.
Goodbye.
Take care.
Spare a coin.
For the infirm.
Are you okay, ma'am?
Oh, gosh.
She looks worse than me.
What is it, citizen?
I'm walking here.
Oh, wait.
Who's this?
Shut up.
His name is Gray Fox?
Wanted for theft, embezzlement, forgery, pit-pocketing, grand
larceny, tax evasion, slander fraud, perfidy, and impertinence.
No.
It can't be.
I killed that guy in Zanzibar land.
No.
He got isekai'd after he...
After he died.
Wears a gray cloak that conceals his appearance.
Presumed male and colovian.
Height between five and six feet.
That's, like, really a big difference.
You must be that ninja.
Normal weight, hair and eye color unknown.
Any citizen with information should contact the Imperial Watch.
That's so funny.
Oh, my gosh.
What is it, citizen?
I know that guy.
Oh, my gosh.
A jester.
Dance for me.
I'm Gemilus Axios, Earl Jackman's manservant.
Oh, he's a manservant.
He did not inform me of your visit.
Oh, who?
Gray Fox.
Oh.
He's that wanted criminal.
Isn't he a master thief?
I hear he's dangerous, too.
I've heard that the beggars spy for him.
He looks really excited about it.
Who are you?
He's that Imperial Watch Captain that's always chasing after the Gray Fox in the Thieves' Guild.
Chasing after shadows, if you ask me.
The Thieves' Guild probably doesn't exist.
And it's a sure bet that Gray Fox doesn't either.
Oh?
This guy is probably Gray Fox.
How much do you want to bet?
Uh-oh.
Guys, the game is, like, breaking my computer.
Oh.
My wallpapers are turning on and off.
Here, I'm going to turn off wallpaper engine real quick.
Pause.
I should do it.
Normal.
Normal behavior.
Yeah.
Okay.
Imperial City.
The Isle is perhaps not well known in the city.
He is a private man and keeps to himself.
Both Thiel from the Arcane University is looking for someone to chase the bandits from Camp Ailes.
Probably trying to enhance her weird machine.
Yeah.
She's weird, huh?
Persuading.
What can I persuade you to do?
Oh.
In each attempt to persuade, you must admire both's joke and coerce.
Each of these actions raises or lowers the character's disposition.
Do not take too long because the character's disposition is steadily falling.
Oh.
Okay.
It's a dating sim?
When you hover each possible action, the character's face shows their reaction to it.
It can be love, like, dislike, or hate.
Their disposition increases if you select a loved or liked action.
Okay.
Oh.
The potential gain or loss for each action is based on your speech craft and how full the wedges.
Try to select fuller wedges when they are aligned with actions the person likes.
All right.
Oh.
I can just bribe them?
I don't even know.
I just want to try it.
I'm going to...
No.
You do me too much honor.
Yeah.
I get it.
He doesn't like these other ones.
Admire.
Wait.
I can't do these.
What?
How do I tell...
You can't scare me.
I can't scare me.
You have to do all four.
Oh.
You're pathetic.
Oh my god.
He said it with a smile.
Okay.
What a waste of time.
How are you today?
Oh god.
Hello.
Yeah?
What?
Are you in love with me or something?
Love at first sight?
Good morning.
The copious coin purse.
Can I sell things here?
He definitely is a gray fox.
The shop where your purse is just as full after you buy.
What does that mean?
Welcome to the copious coin purse.
What kind of deal could I make for you today?
Oh.
Gray fox.
Blasted thief.
I hope they string him up when they catch him.
He's a slippery one though.
The beggars are his eyes and ears.
Um.
So bartering...
Goodbye.
Please come again.
Thanks.
Oh.
I could steal these pumpkins.
I could steal anything in here.
I am the gray fox.
It's me.
Oh.
I could go in there.
How...
I can't even read...
A recipe.
I can't even read on your desk.
Welcome to the copious coin purse.
Why are you so stingy, huh?
Very easy.
Okay.
Bartering equals shop.
You can read the books.
Just don't take them.
Okay.
First edition.
Oh, it's a bookstore?
Speed.
I don't want to say.
Oh, it's a sky again.
Yulam Athram.
Or the Cragenmore Athrams.
Made my fortune in the Flynn trade.
And now I'm here in the city.
Living the life of ease.
Rumors?
The chestnut handy stables now offers to protect your horse.
Seems handy enough.
That's a rumor?
It's not juicy at all.
I could take some.
Is anyone in there?
Whose bed is this?
Why can't I sleep?
The hydrangea is so pretty.
Good day.
Let's see.
We need to go this way.
I guess over that way.
What is it now?
Why are you so rude?
Are you talking to me?
You talking to me?
How do you do?
I'm just exploring a little bit, guys.
Before I...
We're all talking about the Emperor's murder.
Discount spells.
Divine elegance.
Elegance?
Whoa!
The arena.
Take your time.
Oh, Gray Fox.
What's this place?
North Watch Tower.
Where would be a good place to sell my stuff, you guys?
What is it now?
I have not talked to you at all.
So I'm freaky.
Good news.
Everybody's so rude.
Can I go swimming in here?
Is anybody going to judge me for that, too?
An alien can't swim anymore?
An alien can't go fishing in the city's waters?
Any shop we'll buy?
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Then let's...
Sell.
I'm listening.
Go ahead.
The copious coin purse will buy anything?
Okay.
Let's buy...
Let's sell.
Let's sell, baby.
He sounds familiar.
Like his voice actor.
R to haggle.
Have a look around.
You won't find better prices in all town.
R to haggle.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm just going to sell these bear pelts.
For $2.65 gold?
Sure.
Wait, wait.
What do you mean I don't have enough?
Oh, that's not...
Oh, I didn't want to buy.
Oh, good thing.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm buying.
I was going to say, I thought I got rid of the bear pelts before.
Let's see.
Didn't it say it was worth more?
In the dungeon?
Didn't it say...
$4.33?
This was worth...
The bottom right.
Yeah, but like...
Haggle.
Oh.
Buying items at 174% of value.
Selling items at 43%.
Wait.
I want to sell items at the full value.
Why can't I sell at the full value?
Make him like you?
I'm going to try it.
There's no harm, right?
Wait, did it work?
Where'd my stuff go?
Oh, $800.
That's still...
Try to sell?
Should I try to sell the Varla stone?
Or should I sell it some...
Here, I'll try to sell one of these.
I can't make that deal.
Oh!
Rude!
I will take...
You're a satisfied customer.
No!
Actually not!
I will take...
I will take my business elsewhere.
He only has 800 gold?
He owns a store!
Greetings, Imperium.
Ever bought enchanting supplies with you?
I'm syndicates of wizards have led a force on...
Everybody needs a copy of the Black Horse Courier!
The ultimate have power...
Not me.
It could be a dangerous...
An hourglass.
And some shoes.
It's a good day.
I gotta increase my favorability, clearly.
These are...
These are meant for stealing, right?
This is the...
This is the communal...
Sack?
Right, everybody?
Jewelry!
Maybe this guy will...
Whoa!
Oh, I could just take it if I wanted to.
I could take it from you.
Fabio.
But I won't.
Because I'm generous today.
And I'm just trying to figure out how to play this game.
So I'm not causing any trouble right now.
For now.
Why don't you even greet me, huh?
Yes?
It does look like Tommy Wiseau.
It does!
If you need money fast, try Gensine's.
You can sell almost anything there.
Who's Gensine?
What can I interest you in?
Oh, he also has 800.
Now I have...
These stones.
They're very rare.
And very...
Good.
And I would like to sell them.
For...
Um...
All of them.
For 695.
Wait a second.
Yeah.
That's...
It's a lot of gold.
Yeah?
You'll never be able to haggle to 80% like that.
Yes, I will.
You just don't believe.
You need those requests?
Oh.
Never mind, sir.
Be seeing you.
What should I sell, then?
What should I sell?
What do I...
I gotta get rid of stuff, you guys.
I have too many things.
My potions of charisma.
Everybody needs a copy of the Black Horse Courier.
The feed bag.
Alright.
For now, let's just continue the...
The main ingredient.
For now, I'll just continue the quest.
The main story.
In here?
Wait.
I only need one for a quest.
What's your story?
Gosh, you guys are so good at one-guying me.
I'm telling you.
If you...
If you tell me something, I'm gonna believe it.
I've never played this game before.
There's so much.
I'll just believe it.
Hey.
Greetings to you.
I know you.
You should really just sell things at bad prices.
Versus the alternative of dropping them later.
For the Imperial Palace by keeping your voice down.
I'm not speaking.
You're the one yelling at me from across the way.
You've got my ear.
Let's hear it.
What do you want to say?
I'm Jer.
I'm a dip.
A pickpocket.
Oh.
But relax.
You're safe from me.
You look like you might take offense.
Too risky.
So then he won't be offended if I pickpocket from him.
I saw Irene Metric recently.
She jumped clear over a table at the inn.
Something you should believe.
Long hair is cute.
Mint is cute.
Believe it.
Stop.
Farewell.
Are you gonna arrest this guy?
He just admitted to stealing from people.
Wait.
If you see me pickpocket from him.
How does the day greet you, friend?
A chestnut handy stables now offers to protect you.
But your horse seems handy enough.
I've heard others say the same.
Have you heard any word about the other provinces?
They say syndicates of wizards have led a boycott of imperial goods in the land of the Optimus.
It seems Somerset Isle has become a much better.
Oh no.
It's red.
I don't think he'll like it.
Excuse you?
What are you following me for, huh?
Oh, here we go.
Save?
So true.
Okay, here we go.
How does he notice me?
Oh.
Oh, he doesn't.
Red just means it's illegal.
Oh, I'm doing illegal activities there.
A coin for an old beggar.
Speak.
If he's a pickpocket, I'm gonna get him first.
That means he probably has some good stuff.
All right.
You have my ear, citizen.
I don't want to speak to you.
All right.
Three gold.
I got away with it!
Yeah!
Turns out he was just grooming his tail.
Aye, it's a thankless job sometimes, but we wouldn't trade it for the world now, would we?
Is this the guy I need to talk to?
You hear that?
But I heard someone calling for a guard.
I guess that's our cue.
You have my ear, citizen.
Nobody called for a guard.
Guy just wants to get out of the conversation.
Okay.
This way.
For the quest.
He just wanted to leave.
I'm like, oh, I think I'm getting a call right now.
Minto is now mad with power.
Whoa.
My ear, citizen.
Wow.
Mom, give me a picture with this thing.
Cheese.
Say cheese, Ichina.
The arena poster is a reference to the box art of arena.
The very...
The what?
Did you say first scrolls game?
The first elder game?
Nice.
All right.
I need to go in here.
Speak.
My athletics is growing.
What's how...
What's the highest you can get to?
The first game.
Oh.
Neat.
What is it, citizen?
Oh, can I have a horse?
Or...
Paint horse?
Oh.
Can I have that?
State your business, citizen.
A hundred.
He's that thief that the Imperial Watch are always going on about.
He likes to steal from rich folk.
Oh.
Yeah, I've heard of him.
Isn't he a soldier or a guardsman in the Imperial City?
Move along.
I think I need to go far, far away, mister.
And it's...
It's at the request of our now deceased...
I don't know how far of that information...
I've been gone for probably, like, months.
I was stuck in a dungeon.
I don't know how to get it in there.
But our deceased emperor told me to go on this very important mission.
And I require a steed to make it happen with haste.
So you would understand.
Stop, thief.
Stop.
You violated the law.
Since you lack the funds to pay the court...
No!
You must serve out your sentence.
Your stolen goods are now forfeit.
Um...
I'm resisting arrest?
Then pay with your blood!
Oh!
Get me off the horse!
Run!
Run, horse!
Oh, I'm frozen.
Oh, gosh.
Oops.
Is this how you play the game, or...
Oh, wait.
Did I actually not have to go so far?
As far as I thought...
I need to go?
How do I get off the horse?
Oh, my gosh.
Wish I could go faster.
It's pretty far?
Okay, it is far, then.
Sorry that I keep freezing.
I think the game is...
I'm...
Heavy.
A little...
A little heavy.
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
Um...
He won't...
He won't catch up.
I actually don't even know where he is.
Oh, there he is!
Oh!
Go, horse!
Go!
It's E to get off.
Okay.
This is so peaceful.
Yeah, this is really relaxing, actually.
Oh, is that...
Little thing in the top right?
Wait, does that mean I need to sleep?
To level up?
Is that what you guys meant?
It has, like, a moon and a...
Yeah, okay.
So we gotta sleep.
This guy will forget about me, eventually.
Most likely.
Probably.
Ugh.
This is nice.
This is good.
This is...
Really peaceful.
Music's a little, you know...
Doesn't suit the situation, but...
Pretty nice.
It's, you know...
What the hell was that?
Is that a squirrel?
Oh!
Keep going!
Go, horse!
Go!
Fort Ash.
Hey, there's, like, some guy!
He's posing as a...
As a knight!
They're all after me.
Um...
Maybe I should kill them.
So that they forget about me.
You know, like, the hoglins, the piglins, and...
And Minecraft.
If you kill them...
They won't...
Then...
You...
Wait.
I need to go this way.
Oh!
Deliver the amulet!
I already think those guys are.
There he goes.
Slowly but surely.
Oh.
I think he's coming this way.
Your horse is coming back to you!
Try sneaking now.
I think he saw me.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
Oh.
I didn't have mine.
He's powerful.
Oh.
He's...
He's strong.
Oh.
I'm in trouble.
I think I'm in trouble, guys.
Oh.
I'm in trouble.
Wait.
It's for the emperor!
No!
Please!
Oh, gosh.
It's for the emperor!
I promise you!
Oh, gosh.
Ouch.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running,
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running, I'm running A few more.
Slowly but surely.
He's so fast.
Oh my god!
Ah!
That's a kill!
That's a hill!
Run.
Run, run, run.
So close.
Almost got him.
Almost have him.
Your killing has been observed by forces unknown.
It was a self-defense!
Hide the body.
You broke the law.
I needed it to get to here.
This was such a journey.
This was the hardest task I've ever done, ever.
Hello?
Oh, you didn't probably see anything that happened.
I'm the shepherd here.
Eranor's the name.
And this is Waynan Priory.
Waynan Priory.
What's going on?
I see no reason to talk to him.
Oh!
Okay.
If he's not sleeping or eating, he'll be fussing with his books, I reckon, over in the Priory house.
Stop talking!
Oh my god!
They're so rude!
Put my feasts away.
Well, I...
I needed them.
In the...
Priory?
Hey, you know, mister...
I could've really used this horse.
Hey.
Yes?
Um...
I'm gonna woo him over.
Make it quick.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
Uh, he doesn't...
Oh, start.
Yeah.
I don't really understand how this works.
So...
If I like...
You're wasting your bra...
You're pathetic.
Oh!
That...
I like you, too.
I think I get it.
Oh, so the thing that...
Wait.
So you do...
You do...
Sorry.
I'm, like, lagging so bad.
See his face.
No, no.
I get that.
But I don't understand which to start with first, is what I...
You want fewer bars when he doesn't like something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Oh!
That's great!
That's really too much!
Oh, I see, too.
Thank you.
You're pathetic.
Oh!
It went down so much!
I didn't...
Oops.
Oh.
Are you serious?
Sorry.
Um.
I'm done talking to you.
Sorry.
Uh...
You guys...
I'm gonna give the...
Negative res.
Oh, what happened to my personality?
I was supposed to have the wonderful personality.
ET, you're...
You're...
You're messing this up!
You are...
You...
Uh...
Ah!
You had one job!
Hahaha!
Okay, let's go get the amulet.
And then I think I'm gonna call it because the game is like...
Bugging my computer.
It's getting worse.
I fear.
Oh, wow!
Look at that guy!
He's so cute!
Oh.
Can he leave or...
That's probably fine.
Okay, where is this guy at anyway?
In here?
Maybe?
Well met.
Yes?
That Honditar sure knows his way around this area.
Have you spoken with him recently?
I spoke to him recently.
He really knows his way around.
Knows every tree, rock, and cave in the area.
Have you heard any word about the other provinces?
They say syndicates of wizards have led a boycott of Imperial goods in the land of the Ultima.
Where's the...
Where's the subtitles?
Could be a dangerous situation.
Joffrey's chest!
Wait, Joffrey.
Which one of you is Joffrey?
Hello?
Oh!
Can I help you?
I must speak to Joffrey!
He's upstairs.
Go ahead.
That's where I was...
Oh, thank you, sir!
How can I help you?
I don't think he is upstairs.
Oh, there's...
Yes, he is.
I'm brother Joffrey.
What do you want?
I almost stole from his chest right in front of him.
He blended in with the...
With the window.
The Emperor sent me to find you.
Emperor Uriel?
Do you know something about his death?
Oh, wow.
Word spreads really fast.
I was there when he died.
You'd better explain yourself.
Now.
He gave me the Amulet of Kings.
You brought me the Amulet of Kings?
This cannot be.
Let me see it.
By the Nine!
This is the Amulet of Kings.
Who are you?
How did you get this?
What do you know of the Emperor's death?
I'm E.T.
Of...
Of E.T.
Movie fame.
Tell the Emperor's last words.
As unlikely as your story sounds, I believe you.
Only the strange destiny of Uriel Septim could have brought you to me carrying the Amulet of Kings.
Um...
Clothes shut the jaws of Oblivion?
His meaning is unclear to me as well.
Oh.
The Emperor seemed to perceive some threat from the demonic world of Oblivion.
The Prince of Destruction, Mehrunes Dagon, is one of the Lords of Oblivion.
Oh.
But the mortal world is protected from the Daedra of Oblivion by magical barriers.
Ah.
How can Oblivion threaten us then?
I'm not sure.
Only the Emperors truly understand the meaning behind the rituals of coronation.
The Amulet of Kings is ancient.
Saint Alicia herself received it from the gods.
It is a holy relic of great power.
What if they trained?
When an Emperor is crowned, he uses the Amulet to light the Dragonfires at the Temple of the One in the Imperial City.
With the Emperor dead and no new heir crowned, the Dragonfires in the Temple will be dark for the first time in centuries.
In centuries.
It may be that the Dragonfires protected us from a threat that only the Emperor was aware of.
Oh.
The Emperor asked me to find his son.
I am one of the few who know of his existence.
Many years ago, I served as captain of Uriel's bodyguards, the Blades.
The Blades.
One night, Uriel called me into his private chambers.
A baby boy lay sleeping in a basket.
Uriel told me to deliver him somewhere safe.
He never told me anything else about the baby, but I knew it was his son.
From time to time, he would ask about the child's progress.
I hope it's...
Now, it seems that this illegitimate son is the heir to the septic stone.
It's not the guy downstairs, is it?
If he yet lives.
The stable owner?
Where can I find Uriel's son?
His name is Martin.
Martin?
He serves Akatosh in the chapel in the city of Kvatch, south of here.
Normal.
You must go to Kvatch and find him at once.
If the enemy is aware of his existence, as seems likely, he is in terrible danger.
And please, let me know if there's anything you need.
My resources here are limited, but I will help in any way I can.
Thank you, Joffrey.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
He has a lot of information.
Waste no time.
You must find Martin before the enemy does.
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
Guys, I want to keep playing, but I'm afraid for my computer.
Is it illegal to just open it?
What if I don't take anything?
Asking for free goods.
It's just illegal to be curious?
Is curiosity a crime?
Your first priority now should be to find Martin and bring him back here.
Assistant.
I keep a few things here in my chest to resupply traveling blades.
Help yourself to whatever you need.
Thank you, Joffrey.
Where are you going?
He unlocked it for me, even.
Leather.
Steel bow!
Steel bow, baby.
Steel arrow!
Wow, it's garbage.
Not for me!
I only have an iron bow!
Good boy.
Steel bow.
It's like it's my destiny.
Steel.
Steel!
I could have used that against a guy out there who's being a major jerk.
Oh.
Hello.
Brother Piner.
Welcome, good citizen.
I'm Brother Piner.
And this is William Priory.
He said he could have it!
Intense to you.
Can I help you?
Um...
No.
What?
Anvil...
Sorry.
Anvil Chapel attack.
Things go from bad to worse nowadays.
Priests.
Murdered on the chapel altar.
Oh!
What next?
What?
Good day.
Greetings to you.
Nothing.
You can't even look at me.
They're...
They hate me.
Gosh.
I really wanna just do like a...
Absolute...
Sicko mode.
I murder everyone.
I steal everywhere.
I just wanna go off.
The chest that Joffrey opened for you is marked safe too.
It won't respawn its contents.
Oh!
Okay, cool.
Good to know.
I'm glad...
You are getting to enjoy Oblivion.
Oh my goodness.
Stop.
I know they kept some of the more famous bugs in on purpose for nostalgia.
Yeah!
That's why I'm excited to see...
Wayne and Lodge.
It's getting night time.
Are there like different enemies out...
At night?
Wow.
The Aurora Borealis.
Oh, sleep and level up.
Yeah.
I could probably sleep in here.
At this time of year.
This time of day.
Localized entirely in this village.
What?
Why can't I eat the bread?
Am I not a guest here?
Am I not a coveted guest?
How long would you like to sleep?
24 hours.
We'll get a healthy...
Nine...
Eight hours in.
You have ascended to level two!
No mother, it's just the northern lies.
May I see?
I have a visitor.
What do you mean a visitor?
The air grows chill.
What does that mean?
F-S-R?
Go to the ground.
Choose F-S-R.
Upscaling.
Set it to quality.
Or balance.
Oh, thank you.
Actually, I didn't see that.
I didn't check that.
So I don't know.
Let's see.
I wonder if I should...
Do more strength.
I wonder if I should do more strength.
Because I'm so weak when I have to use a sword.
Strength is for the carry...
For the carry weight.
Is that...
I just bit my tongue.
Does that actually have an effect?
Strength.
Endurance.
Intelligence.
F for details.
Oh, thank you.
Defines how much you can carry.
And slightly increases your maximum health.
You know what?
I think I will go with that.
And then...
Endurance is...
Regenerate health...
Out of combat.
And my maximum health.
Intelligence is...
Magicka.
Maybe agility.
My personality sucks.
Which one?
Oh, bows.
Yes, yes, yes.
I was gonna say...
Which one?
Wait, I only read daggers and short swords.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so is...
Does it max at 100?
Yes?
Okay, then it's fine if I kinda keep...
Power...
Put on the...
Agility so we can get to 100 quickly.
Then you move on to a different stat.
Oh...
Ah...
Base maxes at 100.
Okay.
Cool.
I think I'll go with this one.
You sleep rather soundly for a murderer.
Oh my god!
That's good.
A murderer?
You'll need a clear conscience for what I'm about to propose.
Wait, what happened?
Who...
Who are you?
I am Lucian Lachance.
Lachance.
A speaker for the Dark Brotherhood and you.
You are a killer.
No, a self-defense.
Taker of life.
A harvester of souls.
Self-defense.
What?
Your work.
Your death craft.
Pleases the night mother.
The night mom.
And so.
I come to you.
With an authoring.
An opportunity.
To join.
Our rather.
Unique.
Family.
A family?
Oh.
I'm listening.
Then heed my words.
For I will not repeat them.
Oh, okay.
On the green road to the north of Breville.
Lies the inn.
Of ill omen.
Okay.
Very inconspicuous.
Then you will find a man named Rufio.
Kill him.
And your initiation into the Dark Brotherhood.
Will.
Be.
Complete.
Do this.
And the next time you sleep in a location I deem secure.
I will reveal myself once more.
Bearing.
The love.
Of your new family.
currently.
Rufio will die by my hand.
But I'm no murderer.
Slow welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Is this a cult?
Rufia will die by my hand!
Excellent.
Now please, accept this token from the Dark Brotherhood.
It is a virgin blade and thirsts for blood.
May it serve your endeavors well.
Now, I bid you farewell.
I do hope we'll meet again soon.
Soon.
Oh, um, what is the Night Mother?
We praise our unholy matron.
Ryoko!
Welcome to membership, thank you.
From her breast, we suckle malice and pain.
Wow!
She loves her children, you see.
This guy's VA is insane too.
Damn!
Wow!
I'm so glad I joined the Dark Brotherhood.
Have you not heard of the Dark Brotherhood?
No.
Of the remorseless guild of paid assassins and homicidal cutthroats.
Join us, and you'll find the Dark Brotherhood to be all that and so much more.
We are, more than anything, a union of like-minded individuals.
We kill for profit, for enjoyment, and for the glory of the dread father Scythus.
Scythus.
We are family, with bonds forged in blood and death.
And death.
Speaker?
Yes.
I am a speaker, a representative of the Dark Brotherhood.
My voice is the voice of the Black Hand, our organization's ruling body.
One of my duties is to find exceptional individuals, such as yourself.
I killed one guy.
And offer a place within our family.
I guess it's funny because bandits...
Nah, those don't count as people.
Those don't count as murder, but...
But killing a...
But the guard?
Uh...
Any rumors?
Dear sister, I do not spread rumors.
I create them.
How about you?
Know that Rufio is old and weak.
Oh, Rufio I mean.
And sleeps his days away.
Oh, okay.
You could kill him before he even has a chance to wake.
Cool.
If you so choose.
She's messy.
Yeah, he is.
Okay.
Your path is clear.
Send Rufio to his death.
And the Dark Brotherhood will embrace you...
As family.
Thank you, Lucian.
Oh.
He's got stealth camp.
Wait, can I follow him?
Those aren't people!
Rufio.
First you join the Dark Brotherhood.
Then later you become a vampire and become the ruler of the night.
I could see it happening.
What?
That'd be crazy.
Crazy.
Well, he said he was only going to repeat that once.
I just remembered the End of Ill Omens.
Oh.
We'll have to remember that for next time.
Next time, next time.
I don't know for this game since it's kind of like...
I'm trying to decide how I want to stream it.
It might not be like a...
It might kind of just be like a when I feel like it kind of game.
So...
It's in the quest log.
Oh, perfect.
Quests.
Perfect.
Pilgrimage.
Oh, yeah.
Go see Anvil.
A knife in the dark.
Seeking your roots.
Oh, this is the Nern root.
Hmm.
Yeah, I think just kind of whenever I...
Feel like playing it.
I'll probably just be like, you know what?
I'm going to have my schedule this week.
Or something like that.
You know?
It's a slow, comfy game.
I've seen VTubers take years to play through this.
Hot dog.
You did great for a first time player.
I hope you had lots of fun.
I have a feeling you like Dark Brotherhood.
Yeah.
Yes.
We will join the Dark Brotherhood.
And we will cause mischief...
In the night.
Yeah!
So...
Thank you guys for helping me out with...
You know?
I did get one guide a couple times.
But...
I feel that most of you guys...
Um...
Most of you guys tried to help.
So I really appreciate it.
The ETina build is awesome.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Yeah, let's look at ETina one last time.
ETina!
Also...
Didn't we set ET as like old?
So she's like...
She's got nothing to lose.
She's nearing the end of her days.
It doesn't matter if she becomes a murderer...
And an assassin...
And...
Kills for fun.
It doesn't matter.
ETina...
ETina wants to just feel something...
For the little time that she's got left.
So...
Have you heard of the high elves?
You...
Didn't you ask me that earlier?
None!
Nah...
So what?
She's 30?
Nah...
ETina...
ET...
ETina saw what happened with ET...
And decided...
Enough is enough.
I referenced...
The joke.
Oh...
Is it a joke?
Let's see her hair again...
Oh yeah, so true!
Oh...
ETina...
You...
I can't believe...
It looks...
Similar to ET...
I can't believe we actually...
Made ET...
You can look it up on YouTube.
Oh, I will, I will.
But also I want to experience a bunch of more of the...
Lines...
And silly things too.
I know...
I've seen like the mountain lion...
Like...
Clip where you're...
Getting attacked by mountain lions...
And then the guy's like...
Let's see if we can go find those mountain lions.
So...
You know, there's a few things that I have seen.
But there's also so much more that I haven't seen!
So I'm excited...
To experience it all for the first time...
With you guys!
Thank you guys for Oblivion!
Have a good day, have a good night, and...
Wait...
I'm gonna save...
I love ETina!
Yeah!
Otsumito!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye, bye bye!
We'll get more into it next time!
Guy was kinda slow with the tutorial, but...
We'll...
We'll get into it.
Yeah!
Bye bye!
Bye!!!